BUDGET IN FISCAL REVIEW
COMMITTEE WILL COME TO ORDER-
ONE SECOND I BETTER GET MY
GLASSES. SHOW IN RESPONSE THE
CUPBOARD NINETEEN EMERGENCY
PROTECT THE PUBLIC AND R.
EVERYONE IN THE BUILDING WE ARE
LIMITING ITS NONESSENTIAL
GATHERING SENATE HEARING TO
SOCIAL DISTANCING A BASE
COVERING GUIDELINES. AND WE
HAVE ALSO MADE SOME ADJUSTMENTS
TO OUR NORMAL PROCESS EAST WE
ARE HOLDING OUR COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL.
AND WE HOWEVER WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
AND I CAN SEE ON THE SCREEN ARE
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS YOU ALL%
KNOW TO MUTE YOUR PHONES AND
COMPUTERS. AND OF COURSE USED
TO RAISE YOUR HAND FEATURE WHEN
I. RECOGNIZE YOU SO TO ALLOW
PUBLIC ACCESS WE HAVE ADMITTED
PUBLIC TWO TWO HEARING ROOMS
HERE THIS- THIS ROOM RIGHT HERE
IN OUR OVERFLOW ROOM. WERE ALSO
USING A TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
FOR THOSE WHO ARE.
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND IF
YOU WISH TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT IN YOUR REMOTE THE
PUBLIC EXCUSE ME THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS ON OUR
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE
WEBSITE. BUT LET ME READ IT TO
YOU NOW IT IS. 877-226-8152 THE
ACCESS CODE IS. SEVEN EIGHT TWO
ZERO ZERO EIGHT FOUR. NOW IN IN
ORDER FOR US TO HEAR. YOU
CLEARLY. MEETING THOSE OF YOU
WHO CALL IN. YOU MUTE THE
DEVICE YOU ARE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING
TESTIMONY OR IT WILL INTERFERE
WITH YOUR ABILITY TO GIVE US
TESTIMONY. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS
IS CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE
REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE MEETING
SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED. AND WHILE
EVERY EFFORT HAS BEEN MADE TO
STREAMLINE OUR PROCESSING
CONDUCT THE HEARINGS. IN THIS
SAME MANNER AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME INTEREST CUSTOMARY- YOU
KNOW TECHNOLOGY CAN HAVE- IT'S
GLITCHES AND IF WE FACE THOSE
BE PATIENT. LET'S ESTABLISH A
CORN MR SEVEN CHART CAN YOU
CALL THE ROLL. SENATORS
SKINNER. HERE SKINNER HERE.
REAL SOON YES IN HERE COPYRIGHT
COPYRIGHT HERE CORTESE COURTESY
HERE DOLLY. DOLLY HERE TORONTO.
TORONTO HERE TAKE ME TAKE ME IN
HERE GROVE. LAYERED HAIR
LAYERED HERE MAGUIRE. MELINDA'S
MAN MAN HERE NEWMAN NEWMAN HERE
ADOBO TO ABOUT HERE PAN. PM
HERE RAW. S. TURN YOUR TURN
HERE WHY CAL SKI. BREAK OUT THE
KEY HERE. ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A
QUORUM SO. WE ARE MEETING TODAY
TO TAKE UP THE BUDGET BILL THE
PRIMARY BUDGET BILL AB ONE
TWENTY EIGHT AND AS WE ALL KNOW
OUR CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLINE FOR
PASSING A BUDGET IS JUNE
FIFTEENTH SO OUR COMMITTEE
ACTION WILL THEN ALLOW IT TO GO
TO THE FLOOR. THIS BUDGET BILL
THAT WE ARE TAKING UP.
REPRESENTS A BUDGET PLAN THAT
INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED AND SIXTY
ONE POINT FOUR BILLION IN TOTAL
SPENDING A HUNDRED NINETY FIVE
BILLION OF WHICH IS IN GENERAL
POINT ONE NINETY FIVE POINT
FIVE. THAT IS ALMOST A THIRTY
BILLION DOLLAR INCREASE IN
GENERAL FUND SPENDING OVER THE
REVISED CURRENT YEAR LEVEL. THE
BUDGET BILL ALSO REFLECTS AN
ALLOCATION OF TWENTY FIVE POINT
FIVE BILLION IN TOTAL RESERVES.
IT PAYS OFF OUR EDUCATION
DEFERRALS AND MAKES OTHER
PAYMENTS TO DRAWDOWN- PAY DOWN
ON STATE DEBTS AND LIABILITIES
TO HELP US IN THE FUTURE IF WE
HAVE LESS REVENUES WHICH CAN
INEVITABLY HAPPEN. BUT WITH
THOSE WITH PAYING OFF A GOOD
AMOUNT OF DEBT. AND BUILDING UP
THE RESERVES IT WILL GREATLY
ASSIST US. THEY GIVE US GOOD
CHRISTIAN. NOW COMPONENTS OF
THIS BUDGET BILL WERE DISCUSSED
AND VETTED DURING THE
SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS. AND THE
FRAMEWORK WAS DISCUSSED IN OUR
FULL COMMITTEE HEARING. PAST
THE FRAMEWORK ROUTINES AND
BUILDS ON MANY OF THE PROPOSALS
THAT WE RECEIVED FROM THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR THE MAY
REVISE. BUT IT ALSO INCLUDES
VERY IMPORTANT LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES. AND SOME OF THE
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS THAT ARE
CONTAINED WITHIN THIS BUDGET
BILL WE'RE TAKING UP TODAY. ARE
ADDITIONAL AND THESE REFLECT
BOTH ADMINISTRATION AND
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES
ADDITIONAL GRANTS FOR OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND NONPROFITS WHO
HAVE BEEN IMPACTED ECONOMICALLY
BY THE PANDEMIC. EIGHT
EXPANSION OF CHILD CARE AND THE
INCREASE IN THE RATE FOR OUR
CHILD CARE PROVIDERS AND I
THINK ALL OF US HAVE BEEN
PAYING ATTENTION TO THIS
PANDEMIC SAW SO MANY WOMEN.
MANY MORE WOMEN THAN MEN LEAVE
THE WORKPLACE BECAUSE THERE WAS
DURING THE PANDEMIC NO ONE TO
CARE FOR THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS
WHETHER IT WAS CHILDREN. OR
ELDERLY FOLKS OR DISABLED FOLKS
THAT WERE DEPENDENT ON THEM SO
WHEN THE SHUTDOWN OCCURRED AND
WE CAN'T BRING PEOPLE TO BE
CARED FOR HOW THEY OTHERWISE
WERE THEN WHAT HAPPENS
ATTENTION THIS SOCIETY TO FALL
THEN ON THE WOMAN IN THE
HOUSEHOLD AND SO WE SAW MANY
MORE WOMEN LEAVE THEIR JOBS.
AND UNLESS WE CAN RESTORE FULL
CARE FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE NEED
THAT CARE WHETHER IT'S CHILDREN
OR SENIORS OR DISABLED FOLKS IN
WOMEN CANNOT GO BACK TO THE
WORKPLACE IN THE ESTIMATES OF
THE IMPACT OF THIS PANDEMIC ARE
BRINGING BACK WOMEN
ECONOMICALLY BACK TO THE
SEVENTIES AND FOR ONE I FOR ONE
HAVING BECOME A ADULT IN THE
SEVENTIES I DON'T RETURN TO
THAT ECONOMIC STATUS SO. THESE
ASPECTS OF THE PARTS OF OUR
BUDGET THAT CAN RESTORE FUNDING
THAT ARE DISABLED FOLKS ARE
DEPENDENT ON AND BRING BACK OUR
CHILDCARE AND EXPAND OUR
CHILDCARE AND TRANSITION INTO
T. K. ALL OF THOSE ARE
ESSENTIAL NOT ONLY JUST FOR THE
HEALTH OF THE ENTIRE ECONOMY IN
THE SOCIETY BUT CERTAINLY. FOR
THE HEALTH OF WOMEN AND
FAMILIES. ON THE OTHER- REALLY
GREAT NEWS ABOUT THIS BUDGET IS
THAT WE WILL HAVE ACHIEVED PROP
NINETY EIGHT FUNDING THAT IS
FUNDING FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE
SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AT NINETY SIX POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLARS. NINETY SIX POINT ONE
BILLION. WE ALSO HAVE AN
UNPRECEDENTED EXPANSION AND
FINANCIAL AID WHICH WE KNOW IS
ALSO SO NEEDED WHEN WE LOOK AT
THE LEVEL OF STUDENT DEBT. THAT
SO MANY PEOPLE ARE CARRYING. WE
WANT TO TRY TO AVOID THAT WE
WANT PEOPLE TO BE ABLE TO BE
SUCCESSFUL GET THE HIGHER ED
THEY FEEL IT'S NECESSARY
WITHOUT HAVING TO GO INTO
CRIPPLING DEBT. THE OTHER.
THING WE ALL SHOULD BE VERY
PROUD ABOUT IN THIS BUDGET
BILL. IS MULTI YEAR FUNDING TO
DEAL WITH OUR UNSHELTERED
PEOPLE. THOSE WHO ARE LIVING IN
ENCAMPMENTS IN ALL OF OUR
COMMUNITIES THAT ALL OF US KNOW.
NO REASON IN THE RICHEST STATE
IN THE RICHEST ECONOMY OUR
NATION IN THE WORLD THAT WE
WOULD HAVE PEOPLE THAT HAVE TO
LIVE ON OUR STREETS. AND SO WE
ARE GOING TO DO OUR BEST. TO A
THERE'S NO GUARANTEE THAT EVEN
THIS LEVEL OF FUNDING IN FACT
NOT EVEN A GUARANTEE THIS LEVEL
OF FUNDING CAN'T. ALLEVIATE OR
AMELIORATE ALL OF IT BUT WE
HAVE TO MAKE OUR BEST BEST
EFFORT AT. PROVIDING A ROOF
OVER THE HEADS OF MANY MANY
MORE PEOPLE THAN WHO ARE
UNSHELTERED TODAY. WE'VE ALSO
EXPANDED MEDI CAL. FOUR BEDROOM
CALIFORNIA FIFTEEN OVER
REGARDLESS OF THEIR STATUS
BECAUSE IT'S THE APPROPRIATE
THING TO DO. THERE'S ALSO GOOD
FUNDING FOR CLIMATE RESILIENCY
BUT AS I DROVE HERE THIS
MORNING I HEARD
ABOUT THE WE KNOW WE'RE IN A
RECORD DROUGHT WE KNOW HOW DRY
IT IS BUT WHAT WAS I LISTENING
TO IN THE NEWS THIS MORNING
ABOUT THE BIOLOGISTS WERE
MEASURING. THE MOISTURE LEVEL
OF ALL OF THE PLANTS. TREES
SHRUBS- BRUSH ALL THE THINGS
THAT WE KNOW CAN CONTRIBUTE TO
OUR WILDFIRES. AND WHAT THE
REPORT I HEARD IS THEY HAVE
NEVER EVER SEEN. THE VEGETATION
CALIFORNIA AT THIS LEVEL OF
DRYNESS. SO HOW CLIMATE
RESILIENCY WATER IN DROUGHT AND
WILDFIRE THOSE ARE VERY VERY
IMPORTANT PACKAGES IN THIS
BUDGET AND THEY ARE IN THIS
BUDGET AND WE HAVE A COMMITMENT
TO THEM. THERE'S ALSO FUNDING
FOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT FOR
TRANSPORTATION WE KNOW THAT OUR
TRANSIT AGENCIES WERE SEVERELY
IMPACTED WE KNOW OUR WHOLE
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
ALWAYS. IS BENNETT WILL BENEFIT
FROM INFUSIONS OF GOOD
INVESTMENT WHICH WE HAVE HERE
THERE'S SIGNIFICANT
INFRASTRUCTURE INVESTMENTS. AND
GOOD INVESTMENTS IN ACCESS TO
JUSTICE AND SO MUCH MORE. SO I
THINK WE SHOULD ALL FEEL VERY
VERY PROUD THERE'S STILL A LOT
OF WORK TO DO IN REGARDS TO
MEETING THE RESOURCE NEEDS TO
ADDRESS. MANY OF OUR STATE'S
PRESSING NEEDS AND RESIDENTS
NEEDS THIS IS NOT A THIS IS THE
BEST BUDGET I HAVE EVER BEEN
ABLE TO BE PART OF IN ALL THE
YEARS I AM IN THE LEGISLATURE.
AND YET WE WILL STILL HAVE YOU
WILL NOT SOLVE EVERYTHING BUT
WE CAN FEEL GOOD THAT WE ARE
DIRECTING FUNDING TO PLACES
THAT NEED IT SO MUCH. AND THAT
WE ELIMINATED THE TRIGGER CUTS
THAT WERE MADE TO MANY OF OUR
SAFETY NET SERVICES AND TO OUR
HIGHER ED AND OTHER THINGS WHEN
WE WHEN THE PERCEPTION LAST
YEAR WAS THAT WE WOULD BE
FACING A HORRIBLE DEFICIT. WE
ARE NOT FACING HORRIBLE DEFICIT
THANK GOODNESS AND WE HAVE
REMOVED THOSE TRIGGER CUTS. SO
I LOOK FORWARD TO AFTER WE PASS
THIS. REACHING AN AGREEMENT
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION VERY
SOON THE LEGISLATURE IS CLEAR
AND IT IS BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND
THE SENATE THAT WILL BE ACTING
ON THIS BUDGET. SO WE WILL HAVE
SOME GREAT CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION. AND WE WILL
GET TO A PLACE WHERE WE HAVE A
BUDGET THAT EVERYONE. WHAT FEEL
GOOD ABOUT. NOW AFTER HEARING
THE BILL WE WILL HAVE A PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD AND I WILL BE
ASKING THE- POWER AND- PHONE
MODERATOR TO FILL ME IN ON WHAT
THE QUEUE IS SO I CAN DETERMINE
THE TIME PERIOD. BUT IT'LL BE
SOME TIME WE'LL WE'LL HAVE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD BETWEEN
THIRTY THIRTY MINUTES OR FORTY
FIVE DEPENDING ON WHAT THE Q.
AS WE MAY BE ABLE TO GIVE IT A
LITTLE MORE TIME DEPENDING ON
HOW LONG OUR DISCUSSION IS BUT
FOR THE MOMENT. WILL THAT.
TRYING TO PUT IT IN A
CONSTRAINT SINCE WE DO HAVE
FLOOR STASH. POOR SORRY FOR
SESSION TWO DAY. NOW LET ME SEE
IF OUR VICE CHAIR HAS SOME
COMMENTS THAT HE WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
JUST SOME PRACTICING REMARKS.
THIS IS A FAKE BUDGET. IT'S A
FEEL GOOD BUT YOU GET IT LET US
GET PAID BUDGET BUT WHAT WE'RE
VOTING ON IS NOT GOING TO BE
THE BUDGET. NOW I UNDERSTAND
WE'RE UP TO MAYBE NINETY
TRAILER BILLS. BILLS FOR THE
PURPOSE OF. IMPLEMENTING THE
PROVISIONS IN THE BUDGET. THEY
ARE NOT FOR MAJOR POLICY
CHANGES BUT OVER MANY YEARS
WE'VE GOTTEN IN THE HABIT
GOVERNORS AND LEGISLATORS OF
PUTTING MAJOR POLICY. THIS
BUDGET CREATES A BUNCH OF NEW
AGENCIES EVEN. AT NOW THOSE ARE
GOING TO BE BASE BUILDING THOSE
BUDGETS ARE NEVER GOING TO GET
LESS FOR THESE QUOTE NEW
AGENCIES THEY'RE GONNA DO ALL
THESE WONDERFUL THINGS. BUT WE
ALREADY KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
VOTING ON TODAY. YEAH WE'RE
WE'RE PUTTING UP A BUDGET WELL
SURE THAT DOESN'T PASS MUSTER
YEAH I SUPPOSE IT DOES BUT IT'S
KIND OF A FRAUD ON THE PEOPLE
TO MAKE THEM THINK- LOOK AT ALL
THESE WONDERFUL THINGS WERE
GETTING. YEAH THIS YEAR WE HAVE
ACCRUED EXTRA REVENUES. THAT'S
WONDERFUL. AND AS WE DO THAT WE
SHOULD BE PRUDENT IN TERMS OF
WHAT WE SPEND THOSE ON. TO THE
BEST OF OUR ABILITY. TO RETIRE
DEBT. AND WE'RE NOT DOING VERY
MUCH A DEBT RETIREMENT HERE. IN
ONE PARTICULAR PART THAT I
CONSIDER OFFENSIVE. EDT THE
MOST I AGREE JUST AGENCY ALMOST
IN HISTORY OF CALIFORNIA. HOW
MANY OF OUR CITIZENS HAVE BEEN
AGREED BY THAT AGENCY'S REMISS.
IN INEFFICIENCY AND
INCOMPETENCE OVER YEARS. WHAT
WE'RE GONNA HELP THE BUSINESSES
OUT. A LITTLE BIT. BUT OVER A
DECADE GEE THAT'S REALLY GREAT.
THEY NEED HELP NOW WHY DO WE
HAVE TO DEFER THE IMPACT ON
THEM AND THE CITIZENS THAT WE
REPRESENT WHO HAVE BEEN HARMED
BY THAT AGENCY. HOPEFULLY
BIPARTISAN WAY MEMBERS ARE
WORKING TOGETHER. TO HAVE SOME
DRASTIC CHANGES. IN THE CONDUCT
OF EDT. THIS LEGISLATURE DARE
NOT ADJOURN WITHOUT DRASTICALLY
CHANGING STATUTORY. THE MISSION
AND CONDUCT OF THAT AGENCY.
WE'RE NOT DOING THAT HERE. AND
I WOULD RATHER SEE THAT BE DONE
HERE. BUT WE HAVE NO IDEA WHAT
THE IMPLEMENTING SO CALLED
TRAILER BILLS. ARE GOING TO
HOLD FOR US WHENEVER WE GET
AROUND TO DOING THAT. AND
REMEMBER WE COULD STILL BE
DOING TRAILER BILLS NEXT YEAR.
IMPLEMENTING THE PROVISIONS OF
THIS BUDGET I WOULD ARGUE
MEMBERS TO. THOUGH THERE'S A
LOT OF REVENUE HERE THE STROLL
AROUND. A LOT OF THINGS THAT
COULD BE FUNDED. BUT SOME
THINGS ARE HUGE ONGOING
OBLIGATIONS AFFECTING FUTURE
BUDGETS. IMPACTING FUTURE
DEFICITS. DO NOT FORGET WHAT
HAPPENED DURING THE DAVIS
ADMINISTRATION. THE DAVIS
ADMINISTRATION CAME IN WITH A
BIG SURPLUS. AND BOY DID
EVERYBODY SPEND EVEN
REPUBLICANS GOT THEIR PIECE OF
THE ACTION. WITH SOME GIVE BACK
THE VOTERS. BUT WHAT THEN
HAPPENED. WE CONCRETIONS THE
BASE BUDGET. I BELIEVE WAS TWO
YEARS LATER WITH CROWD CROWDED
AWAY INTO TWENTY FOUR BILLION
DEFICIT AND THEN A FORTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLAR DEFICIT. I
PREDICT THAT THAT'S WHERE THIS
BUDGET IS HEADED. TWO TO FOUR
YEARS OUT HUGE DEFICITS BECAUSE
OF THE BUILT IN AUTOMATIC
OBLIGATIONS THAT WE'RE FINDING
HERE. AND WHAT ARE THE SHEET TO
THE MOTORING PUBLIC TO. WE HAD
TO RAISE THE GAS TAX WE HAD IN
THE EXIT. THE NDP'S EVERYTHING
HAD TO BE. INCREASED AND
INDEXED. WELL WHEN WE GET THE
TAXPAYERS A LITTLE BREAK THE
MOTORING PUBLIC A LITTLE BREAK
AND REDUCE THEIR BUT- BIRDS
SOMEONE AGAIN I WOULD ARGUE
THAT THIS IS WORTHY OF A NO
VOTE AND WE'LL CONTINUE OUR
DISCUSSION AND HAVE OTHER
QUESTIONS MADAM CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK. THANK YOU MR VICE CHAIR
CLEARLY- EVERYONE ON OUR IN OUR
COMMITTEE AND IN OUR HOUSES IN
TOTAL THERE OPINIONS. I WOULD
SAY THAT THE TERM FEEL GOOD
OBVIOUSLY CAN HAVE DIFFERENT
MEANINGS. I WILL TAKE FEEL GOOD
ABOUT THIS BUDGET AS A POSITIVE
BECAUSE I FEEL GOOD ABOUT THIS
PROJECT. AND THIS IS NOT A
FIXED BUDGET WHILE THERE COULD
BE OBVIOUSLY DISCUSSIONS ABOUT
WHETHER IT ADEQUATELY PAYS OFF
DEBTS. OR WHETHER IT CREATES-
FUTURE- COSTS THAT. MAY THEN
HAVE TO BE MODIFIED IF WE DO
FACING ECONOMIC CURRENT
DOWNTURN. WE WILL FACE THAT BUT
CERTAINLY IF WE TAKE FOR
EXAMPLE INVESTMENTS IN CHILD
CARE TO NOT INVEST NOW BECAUSE
WE FEAR THAT THERE WOULD BE
SOME REDUCTION IN REVENUES IN
THREE TO FOUR YEARS WHAT IS THE
IMPACT ON THAT ZERO TO THREE
CHILD. THAT THEY DO NOT GET THE
QUALITY CARE AND EDUCATION THAT
WILL ALLOW THEM TO THRIVE AND
ALLOW OUR ECONOMY TO THRIVE
LATER BECAUSE THEY HAVE
THRIVED. YOU CAN'T GET THAT
BACK SO I WOULD PREFER TO. DO
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR THOSE
BASIC NEEDS AND- AND IF WHEN WE
FACE SOME REVENUE DROPS WHICH
ARE INEVITABLE WE KNOWS
ECONOMICS CYCLES WE HAVE
QUESTIONS. THERE'S NOTHING FAKE
ABOUT THIS BUDGET THERE IS
QUESTION. AND IF. HORRENDOUSLY
WE FACE SOMETHING LIKE TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHAT WE ADOPTED TODAY
EVEN IF WE PUT TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHT WE HOPE WILL NEVER EVER
BE REPEATED. BACK TO PLAN
SOLELY FOR THAT TYPE OF A- A
BUDGET CURRENTS DOESN'T MAKE
SENSE BECAUSE OF THE HARM THAT
WE COULD CAUSE NOW. IN TRYING
TO IMAGINE PREVENTING HARM OF
THE FUTURE LET US DO OUR BEST
TO NOT CREATE HARM NOW. AND
THAT IS WHAT I FEEL THIS BUDGET
DOES AND IT IS PRUDENT. AND IT
IS NOT FAKE. AND WITH THAT WE
WILL START. HERE FROM OUR
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST MR PADDOCK
WHO WILL PRESENT- I'M SORRY
APOLOGIES PLEASE MY PHONE I AM
VERY SORRY I'M SORRY. ED CENTER
LAYERED STRAHAN WAS UP FIRST.
CENTERMAN GO AHEAD DO IT. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I WANT TO
START OFF BY SAYING THANK YOU
TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF IN OUR
SENATE LEADERSHIP- INCLUDING
YOU OUR BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
CHAIRS- AND OUR STAFF FOR THEIR
HARD WORK GOING THE BUDGET ACT
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE I ALSO
FEEL GOOD ABOUT THIS BUDGET AND
IT'S A HISTORIC BUDGET THANKS
TO RESPONSIBLE BUDGETING LAST
DECADE STRONG STIMULUS FAMILY
PAYMENTS THAT KEPT STRUGGLING
FAMILIES AFLOAT AND PREVENT A
COMPLETE ECONOMIC COLLAPSE
DURING THE CALL BUT NINETEEN
PANDEMICS. AND ALSO BECAUSE OF
LONG RUN INVESTMENTS THAT
CREATED THE UNIQUE CONDITIONS
HERE IN THE STATE FOR SUSTAINED
GROWTH NEARLY 40% OF JOBS
CREATED THIS YEAR HAVE COME
FROM THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
ARE UNIQUELY STRONGLY
POSITIONED RIGHT NOW IS AN
ECONOMY AND THAT'S BECAUSE
WE'VE MADE STRONG INVESTMENTS
IN THINGS LIKE EDUCATION AND
SMALL BUSINESSES AND I'M PROUD
TO SEE THAT THIS BUDGET DOES A
LOT OF THAT GOING FORWARD AND I
WANT TO PARTICULARLY THANK AND
APPLAUD THE CHAIR OF THE
SUBCOMMITTEE I SIT ON SENATOR
LAYERED- WHO'S BEEN
INSTRUMENTAL IN FURTHERING
HISTORIC INVESTMENTS. IN E. C.
E. K. TWELVE AND HIGHER ED AND
HIS ROLE AS SUB ONE CHAIR-
THESE INVESTMENTS IN EDUCATION
ARE GOING TO BE ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL FOR SUSTAINED ECONOMIC
PROSPERITY GOING FORWARD- WE
HAVE TO BE NOT THE OPPOSITE OF
PENNYWISE POUND FOOLISH- WE
HAVE TO ENSURE THAT OUR
EDUCATION SYSTEM EDUCATES OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE EDUCATES OUR
COLLEGE STUDENTS CREATES
COLLEGE AFFORDABILITY SO THAT
THOSE YOUNG PEOPLE WILL GROW UP
AND BECOME THE BASIS OF A
STRONG ECONOMY GOING FORWARD.
I'M ALSO PROUD THAT THIS BUDGET
INCLUDES THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
THE OFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY AND
API LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS PRIORITY
AN IMPORTANT STEP TOWARDS
ADVANCING RACIAL EQUITY IN
STATE GOVERNMENT ONE POINT FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS MORE TOWARDS
THIS CALIFORNIA SMALL BUSINESS
COBRE NINETEEN RELIEF GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH HAD BEEN
PREVIOUSLY FUNDED THREE SP
EIGHTY SEVEN AUTHORED BY
SENATOR CAFIERO AND MYSELF-
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED MILLION
TOWARDS PREVENTING GUN VIOLENCE
IN THE STATE AND FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS TO SUPPORT
DOMESTIC AND- VIOLENCE
PREVENTION. AMONG OTHERS THESE
TYPES OF HISTORIC INVESTMENTS
ARE NOT ONLY FEEL GOOD NOW THEY
AGAIN WILL HAVE LONG RUN
EFFECTS THAT WILL CREATE THE
CONDITIONS FOR SUSTAINED
ECONOMIC PROSPERITY IN THE LONG
RUN. I DO WANT TO SAY THAT
THROUGH FURTHER DISCUSSION I
HOPE WE CAN CONTINUE IMPROVING
THIS BUDGET- AND ADDRESSING
OTHER LONG RUN PRIORITIES
INCLUDING CLIMATE CHANGE IN THE
CRISIS THAT WE'RE NOW FACING I
WOULD LOVE TO SEE MORE
INVESTMENT IN THE RESEARCH
DEVELOPMENT AND INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT CAN HELP US REALLY TRY TO
MEET DEMAND IMPATIENCE MANDATES
THAT OUR STATE IS SET AND
CONTINUE TAKING THAT STRONG
LEADERSHIP ROLE IN SAVING OUR
CIVILIZATION FROM THE CLIMATE
EMERGENCY THAT WE'RE NOW
FACING. IN TERMS OF EDUCATION I
WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WHATEVER
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
SYSTEM WE END UP ADOPTING IS
FAVORABLE TO ALL PARTIES IS
DONE WITH THE SUSTAINABLE
FRAMEWORK AND IS NOT
DETRIMENTALLY AFFECT THE
AVAILABILITY OR COST OF CHILD
CARE TO PEOPLE IN THE STATE.
WHILE THESE ITEMS ARE NOT
CURRENTLY IN THIS BUDGET I LOOK
FORWARD TO MAKING SURE THEY ARE
INCLUDED AS WE FINALIZE OUR
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE GOVERNOR-
I WANNA FINALLY JUST SAY. WE
HAVE A STRONG ECONOMY RIGHT NOW
BUT THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
STRUGGLING. THEY'RE PEOPLE IN
MY DISTRICT AND ALL OF OUR
DISTRICTS THAT ARE STRUGGLING
RIGHT NOW- AND WHEN WE WELL WE
SEE THAT THE FUTURE OF OUR
ECONOMY IS BRIGHT- THAT DOES
NOT MEAN A LOT TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE BARELY GETTING BY RIGHT NOW
AND SO- I. AM VERY PROUD OF THE
WORK THAT YOU WE ALL HAVE DONE
IN TRYING TO ADDRESS THE NEEDS
OF PEOPLE NOW. WHILE BALANCING
THAT WITH THE LONG RUN PRIOR TO
THE STATE I WANT TO THANK
LEADERSHIP AGAIN AND EVERYONE-INVOLVED IN THIS BUDGET FOR
THESE HISTORIC STATE
INVESTMENTS AND I LOOK FORWARD
TO SUPPORTING THIS BUDGET TODAY.
SENATOR LAYERED. THANK YOU VERY
VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR I WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE- THE
ARCHITECTURE OF THE BUDGET WAS
ADDRESSED IT IN THE LIGHT OF
COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
COMPARING THIS TO THE SITUATION
OF TWENTY YEARS AGO. BECAUSE I
ARRIVED IN THE LEGISLATURE
EIGHTEEN YEARS AGO THE DEFICIT
WAS ROUGHLY TEN BILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR UNTIL THE GREAT
RECESSION IT WAS BECAUSE TAXES
WERE CAUGHT THERE WAS NO
RESEARCH AND SO NOW. ARE YOU
WHAT DIDN'T GET MENTIONED IS
THAT N. SEVENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS OF EXTRA STATE MONEY WE
HAVE A TWENTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLAR ROUTE IN TOTAL RESERVES
TWENTY FIVE BILLION DOLLARS
THAT DIDN'T EXIST BEFORE AND
THAT REALLY IS DESIGNED TO EVEN
OUT THE BOOM AND BUST OF THE
BUDGETS WE HAVE A I THINK THE
NUMBERS ELEVEN BILLION IS IN
STIMULUS IT'S A ONE TIME AND IT
GOES TO THE PEOPLE THAT HAVE
BEEN STRUGGLING THE MOST IN
THIS PERIOD OF TIME. AND SO
THAT REALLY ARE TRIES TO EVEN
OUT TO WHERE WE ARE IN THE
ECONOMY THIS BUDGET DOES PAY
OFF DEBTS YEAH THE DEFERRALS
THAT EXISTED WERE FOR EDUCATION
WE'RE NOT EVEN PROPOSED TO BE
COMPLETELY PAID OFF IN THE
PROPOSED BUDGET THIS BUDGET
DOES IT SO THAT THE- INTERESTED
TWO CREWED BY LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICTS WILL NOT BE APPROVED
THE DEFERRAL WAS PAID OFF AND
THEN THERE ARE DISH NO ONE TIME
EXPENDITURES ONE FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS FOR. HIGHER EDUCATION
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION OTHERWISE
WE WOULD BE ASKED TO DO A BOND
WE WOULD BE ASKED TO PAY MAYBE
A DOLLAR EIGHTY CENTS FOR EVERY
DOLLAR THAT WENT TO BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION INSTEAD OF PUTTING
AN END TO A BOND AND INCURRING
THAT DEBT WE'RE DOING A ONE
TIME EXPENDITURE FOR THE FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS WE'RE
RECOMMENDING IN THIS BUDGET. SO
AND THEN IF YOU LOOK AT THE
FACT THAT THERE ARE INCREASED.
ON GROWING REVENUES WE IN DRESS
IMPACT THOSE ISSUES THAT WERE
MENTIONED BY THE CHAIR. WHETHER
IT'S HOMELESSNESS CHILD CARE
SLOTS HEALTH CARE- A DEBT FREE
COLLEGE PRESCHOOL AND SO THIS
IS A VERY SOUND BUDGET THAT.
WITH ONGOING REVENUES ADDRESSES
WHAT WE NEED TO DO FOR IMPACT
AND IS REALLY SOUND WITH A
LARGE AMOUNT OF RESERVES A
LARGE AMOUNT OF ONE TIME MONEY
GOING TO THE PEOPLE THAT NEED
IT. A LARGE AMOUNT ONE TIME
MONEY AVERTING THE NEED FOR
BONDS A LARGE AMOUNT OF ONE
TIME MONEY PAYING OFF DEBT.
THIS IS SOUND FISCAL WAY AND I
JUST THOUGHT IT WAS VERY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE THOSE POINTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
LAYER DOES WERE VERY IMPORTANT
POINTS IN YOUR- I'M SURE YOU.
COULD HAVE ALSO INCLUDED THE
FACT THAT NOT ONLY ARE WE NOT
DOING A BLIND FOR THAT
NECESSARY INFRASTRUCTURE AT OUR
HIGHER EDUCATION WHICH OF
COURSE. CREATES DEBT WE ARE
INVESTING IN IT DIRECTLY WE'RE
ALSO DOING SIMILARLY FOR
CLIMATE RESILIENCY. AND SO WE
ARE ADDRESSING WITH THE
REVENUES WE HAVE NOW. THOUGH
CLIMATE RESILIENCY AND IN THE
FUTURE YES WE MAY HAVE TO SOME
POINT WELL WELL INTO THE FUTURE
CONSIDER A BOND BUT AT THIS
POINT WE'RE NOT HAVING TO DO
THAT AND BY NOT DOING IT WE ARE
NOT CREATING DEBT AS YOU
POINTED OUT. AND I'M SURE WHEN
THE LA- PRESENTS. THEY WILL
POINT OUT. THAT THIS BUDGET. IS
STRUCK. DOWN THROUGH THE NEXT
FOUR FISCAL YEARS SO WHEN I
REFERRED. THAT OCCURS WE KNOW
THE ECONOMY IS IT HAPPENS. FOR
THE NEXT FOUR YEARS THERE IS NO
PROJECTED OUT YEAR DEFICITS. SO
IN THAT RESPECT I WAS VERY
ACCURATE IN THIS NOT BEING A
FAKE BY CHECK. AND LET ME CALL
ON SENATOR EKMAN. ALL RIGHT ANY
OTHER YES SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST LIKE TO
MAKE A COUPLE COMMENTS ON.
WE'RE DEBATING OVER A BUDGET
THAT HAS. A LOT OF MONEY IN IT
AND I THINK IT'S- THERE ARE
SOME PRUDENT THINGS IN HERE
ABOUT PAYING ONE TIME DEBTS.
BUT WHAT I WANT TO COMMENT ON
IS WHAT ARE THE DELIVERABLES TO
ME IT'S NOT. SO MUCH ABOUT THE
MONEY IT'S ABOUT THE POLICY OF
HOW WE ACTUALLY IMPLEMENT. WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH. A
FEW YEARS BACK WE WORKED ON.
THE WATER BORNE INTO MANY
MEMBERS IN HERE WE WORKED
REALLY HARD TO PASS A BOND.
THAT WOULD. CREATE MORE WATER.
IT WAS A DIFFICULT BATTLE WE
WENT BACK AND FORTH WE TALKED
ABOUT STORAGE. AND HERE WE ARE.
SIX YEARS LATER AND WE HAVEN'T.
CREATED ONE GALLON OF WATER
STORAGE AND WE'RE IN A DROUGHT.
SO WE HAVE BROADBAND SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN THIS BUDGET.
OVER A PERIOD OF TIME THERE'S
COUNTLESS BILLS MOVING THROUGH
THE LEGISLATURE. BUT WE REALLY
DON'T HAVE A PLAN ON EXACTLY
HOW THAT'S GOING TO WORK. AND
SO I PROPOSE THAT. ON THE- THE
WATER THE MONEY GOING FOR. YOU
COMMUNITY SERVICE DISTRICTS AND
HOW WE NEED DETAILS WE NEED
DETAIL OF HOW THAT'S GOING TO.
PLAY OUT AND HOW IT'S ACTUALLY
GOING TO BE THE DELIVERABLES ON
THE GROUND WITH THE SAME THING
WITH BROADBAND. LOOK WE HAVE
ALL THESE BILLS WE NEED. A
COMMITTEE TO SIT DOWN WITH ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS THAT ARE
TRYING TO GET SOMEWHERE AND
ACTUALLY PUT A POLICY IN PLACE
THAT DELIVERS WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH I THINK. THE
PERSPIRATION FOR ME MORE THAN
ANYTHING IS THAT IT'S NOT A
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE MONEY
GOVERNMENT ALWAYS THROWS MORE
MONEY AT IT BUT THE POLICY. IS
THE PROBLEM. SO I WOULD
ENCOURAGE THIS BUDGET COMMITTEE
TO REALLY LOOK AT THE POLICY
AND WHAT IS THE DELIVERABLE AT
THE END OF ALL THIS. HUGE
AMOUNT OF MONEY WE'RE GONNA BE
PUSHING OUT MORE MONEY THAN
WE'VE EVER PUSHED OUT INTO A
BUDGET BUT HOW IS IT REALLY
GOING TO AFFECT THE PERSON
THAT'S IN THE INNER CITY THAT'S
IN A HOUSING PROJECT FOR THE
BROADBAND THAT'S WHAT I WANT TO
KNOW. I WANT TO KNOW ARE WE
REALLY GONNA DELIVER. ARE WE
GONNA DELIVER WATER BUT WE GET
IT WE DID SOME EARLY ACTION
ITEMS FOR THE FIRE WE KNOW
WE'RE GOING TO IT'S AS THIS IS
THE CHAIRMAN STATED. IT'S GONNA
BURN IT'S THE MOISTURE IS BEING
SUCKED OUT EVERY DAY I HAVE
NEVER SEEN WIND. LIKE THIS IN
THIS EARLY IN THE YEAR- ON OUR
FARM AND SO THAT'S TAKING
MOISTURE OUT OF OUR PLANTS. SO
WE DID SOME EARLY ACTION IS BUT
FOR ME VENTURE MEMBERS I WOULD
LIKE TO FOCUS ON. THE POLICY IT
ACTUALLY. SPENDS THIS MONEY AND
HOW IT'S GOING TO. BECOME
DELIVERABLES TO THOSE PEOPLE
WHO DESPERATELY NEED IT AND
THAT INCLUDES BUSINESSES WITH
THEIR ET DE PAY BACKS OVER TIME
THOSE ARE THE THINGS THAT WE
SHOULD FOCUS ON AND I KNOW.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE. NINETY
SOME TRAILER BILLS AND THAT'S
WHAT THE POLICY IS REALLY GOING
TO BE. THIS IS THE OVERALL
BUDGET. IT SETS THE AMOUNT
WHICH IS. HUGE BUT WE REALLY
NEED GOOD POLICY IF WE'RE GONNA
DO THE RIGHT THING BY
CALIFORNIANS IN THIS ONE TIME
OPPORTUNITY WE HAVE TO GET IT
TO THE GROUND AND IT HAS TO
WORK THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU SO LET'S HEAR FROM
LMAO AND THEN WE WILL HAVE A
LITTLE MORE CONTENT BEFORE
ASSISTIR WHAT WE ARE. ACTING ON
TODAY SO MR PADDOCK WILL YOU
PLEASE BEGIN THE PRESENTATION
OF A B. ONE TWENTY EIGHT AND-
YOU JUST- GO AHEAD. OKAY VERY
GOOD THANK YOU AND GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR- THANK YOU FOR
INVITING ME- MR VICE CHAIR AND
SENATORS- MY NAME IS GABE
PADDOCK AND LEGISLATIVE ANALYST
AND- I'M JOINED TODAY BY SOME
OF MY COLLEAGUES ONLINE AS WELL
TO- RESPOND ANY QUESTIONS THAT
YOU MAY HAVE AFTERWARDS- TODAY
I WOULD HAVE TO PROVIDE YOU
WITH A BREF. OVERVIEW OF THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE. AND SO
HOPEFULLY YOU HAVE A COPY OF
THIS- SHORT TWO PAGE HANDOUT
THAT I- CIRCULATED. THAT WE
PROVIDED- SO I'LL BEGIN WITH
THAT- ON THE FIRST PAGE OF IT-
AND AS THE CHAIR. MENTIONED THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE INCLUDES A
HUNDRED AND NINETY SIX BILLION
IN GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES-
THE PACKAGE- IT USES THE
REVENUE ESTIMATES FROM OUR
OFFICE. ADJUSTED FOR ADDITIONAL
FINAL TAX COLLECTION IN APRIL
AND MAY WHICH HAD THREE POINT
NINE BILLION TO OUR REVENUE
ESTIMATES. THESE FINAL TAX
PAYMENTS CAME IN AFTER WE HAD
CLOSED THE BOOK ON OUR BOOKS ON
OUR FORECAST SO- THAT'S WHERE
THE BILLS ARE COMING FROM. AND
SO THEN OVERALL OUR REVENUE
ESTIMATE IS ABOUT EIGHT BILLION
HIGHER THAN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE ESTIMATES WERE. AND IN
THAT PACKAGE THIS IS AN ALMOST
EXACTLY OFFSET BY THE ESTIMATED
COST OF THE GOLDEN STATE
STIMULUS TWO POINT NO PAYMENTS
AND THOSE ARE SCORED IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE AT OUR RICK
REVENUE REDUCTION. A COUPLE OF
OTHER POINTS ON THIS FIRST PAGE
THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGING USES
AROUND SEVEN POINT THREE
BILLION OF THE FEDERAL AMERICAN
RESCUE PLAN FUNDS TO OFFSET
GENERAL FUND COSTS AND IN
ADDITION TO THAT. THE PACKAGE
AS SOON AS THE- HIGHER FEDERAL
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES AND
USES THE ENTIRE- FEDERAL FUNDS
TO PAY FOR THE IT CBS
AUGMENTATIONS AS REQUIRED BY
THE FEDERAL. GUIDELINES AND
THEN LASTLY ON THIS STAGE BUT
IT'S MENTIONED- THE RESERVES
THAT THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE
DOES HAVE A TOTAL OF TWENTY
POINT THREE BILLION IN RESERVES
NOT INCLUDING THE FIVE POINT
THREE BILLION AND- PROP NINETY
EIGHT RESERVE- AND THEN- WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE
LEGISLATIVE. PACKAGE DOES
ALLOCATE ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
AND FIFTY MILLION TO INCREASE
THE SAFETY NET RESERVE BRINGING
THE BALANCE IN THAT
DISCRETIONARY RESERVE TO ONE
POINT TWO BILLION. OKAY MOVING
TO THE SECOND PAGE I WILL JUST-
COVER A FEW OF THE MAJOR
CHOICES THAT ARE MADE IN THE
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE. FIRST AS
HAS BEEN DISCUSSED ALREADY- THE
PACKAGE PROVIDES A TOTAL OF
NINETY SIX BILLION FOR
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT. OF
THIS SIXTY NINE BILLION IS FROM
THE GENERAL FUND. AND IT DOES
INCLUDE SUBSTANTIAL ALLOCATION
TO ONE TIME ACTIVITIES WHICH
HAS OUR OFFICE HAS DESCRIBED
BEFORE DOES CREATE UPROOTING
QUESTION IN THE EVENT THAT-
FUTURE- IN THE FUTURE THE
PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
GUARANTEE LEVEL WERE TO DECLINE.
AMONG THE ONE TIME ALLOCATIONS
THIS HAS ALSO BEEN MENTIONED.
THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE
REPLACES FIVE BILLION AND- MAY
REVISION ONE TIME SPENDING
WITH- TO TWO AREAS- TWO POINT
SIX BILLION OF IT GOES TO PAY
OFF THE REMAINING- K. THROUGH
TWELVE DEFERRALS AND THEN. THE
BALANCE OF THAT FIVE FIVE
BILLION- IN ONE TIME FUNDING
WOULD GO TO THAT. ADDRESS SOME
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES
INCLUDING A HIGH SCHOOL BLOCK
GRANT INCLUSIVE EARLY EDUCATION
EXPANSION. AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DEFERRED MAINTENANCE.
WHEN IT COMES TO ONGOING
SPENDING COMPARED TO THE MAY
REVISION THE LEGISLATIVE
PACKAGE HAS ABOUT TWO BILLION
IN ADDITIONAL. FUNDING FOR K.
FOURTEEN PROGRAMS. IN THE IN
THE ON THE- WITHIN K. TWELVE
EDUCATION THE LARGEST
AUGMENTATIONS ARE WERE SPECIAL
EDUCATION BASED FUNDING AND
STATE PRESCHOOL SLOT AND RATE
INCREASES. IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES THE LARGEST INCREASES
ARE FOR A VARIETY OF
CATEGORICAL PROGRAMS. AND A
HIGHER- BASE OF COURSE IN MEN'S
INCREASED. THEN WHEN WE MOVED
TO THE NON PROPOSITION NINETY
EIGHT SIDE OF THE BUDGET THE
PACKAGE INCLUDES SIGNIFICANT
ALLOCATIONS FOR. DROUGHT AND
WILDFIRE IS THAT RESILIENCE AND
RELATIVE TO THE MAY REVISION IT
INCREASES OTHER- CLIMATE
RELATED ACTIVITIES AND IT'S-
IT'S ALSO BEEN TALKED ABOUT A
LITTLE BIT HERE- NO THE PACKAGE
ALSO INCLUDES LARGE ALLOCATIONS
TO- HOMELESS MISS RELATED-
ACTIVITIES SUCH AS PROJECT HOME
KEY. AND THE- COMPARED TO THE
MAY REVISION PROVIDES A HIGHER
LEVEL OF FLEXIBILITY TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES FOR SERVICES
TO THOSE THAT EXPERIENCING
HOMELESSNESS. AND IN ADDITION
WITHIN THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES THE
PACKAGE INCLUDES TWO HUNDRED
AND SEVENTEEN MILLION TO FIND
TO BEGIN. THE THREE YEAR PHASE
IN OF THE RATE MODELS THAT WERE
PROPOSED BY THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN DDS- RATE STUDY- THAT
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTEEN
MILLION IN TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWO IT'S FOR HAPPIER COST OF
FEEDING IN THE RATE INCREASES.
AND BY THE FINAL YEAR OF THE
MULTI YEAR AND- BUT I'M SORRY
APPLE IN THE IMPLEMENTATION
WHICH IS- TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR- THEY WOULD AT A COST OF
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FORTY SEVEN
MILLION. THE PACKAGE IN
ADDITION. PROVIDES
APPROXIMATELY FOUR HUNDRED
MILLION IN ONGOING FUND AND
SEVENTY MILLION IN ONE TIME
FUNDS TO UPDATE OR MODERNIZE.
ELEMENTS OF THE STATE PUBLIC
HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE. ALSO
THERE IS- SIXTY SIX AND A HALF
MILLION TO EXPAND ELIGIBILITY
FOR FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL TO
INCOME ELIGIBLE ADULTS OVER AGE
FIFTY REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS AND THE COST OF THIS
EXPANSION. WOULD GROW TO AROUND
ONE POINT THREE BILLION UPON
FULL IMPLEMENTATION- ONE
EXAMPLE THAT WE WANTED TO
MENTION ALSO IS THAT THE
PACKAGE DOES THE INTERNET IN
EXAMPLE OF- BUDGET RESILIENCE
THE PACKAGE DOES INCLUDE A
BILLION IN FUNDS TO PREPAY-
SOME OF THE STATE FUNDED DEBT
SERVICE. AND THEN FINALLY-
ARTIST- AT THE MENTION BRIEFLY
THAT THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE
DOES INCLUDE SUBSTANTIAL
AUGMENTATIONS FOR STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID. INCLUDING THE
PELL GRANT PROGRAM AND THE
MIDDLE CLASS SCHOLARSHIP-
PROGRAM BOTH- INCLUDE EXPANDED
ELIGIBILITY AND INCREASE THE
WORD SIZES SO- I'LL STOP THERE
AND- ALONG WITH MY COLLEAGUES
WOULD BE HAPPY TO RESPOND TO
ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE.
THANK YOU LET'S HEAR FROM DO
YOU F. FIFTY F. HAS ANY
COMMENTS AND THEN WE CAN SEE IF
THERE ARE SOME QUESTIONS I
CERTAINLY HAVE A QUESTION FOR
THE LA- BUT GO AHEAD. DO YOU F.
AND MORNING MADAM CHAIR- MR
VICE CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ACTUALLY WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE AGAIN- I
MADE
REMARKS ON THE SENATE PLAN-
THAT'S NOT INCLUDED IN EIGHTY
ONE TWENTY EIGHT. AT THE
COMMITTEE'S LAST HEARING SO I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO BRIEFLY SAY
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION LOOKS
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
LEGISLATURE. OVER THE NEXT
SEVERAL DAYS NOW- TO COME UP
WITH A FINAL BUDGET AGREEMENT
THAT MAINTAINS A STRONG FISCAL
FOUNDATION THAT DOESN'T OVER
COMMIT THE STATE TO- LONG TERM
SPENDING THAT IT CANNOT AFFORD
IT WHICH COULD POTENTIALLY LEAD
TO CUTS IN THE FUTURE TO CORE
PROGRAMS- BUT IMPORTANTLY WE
LOOK FORWARD TO BUILDING A
BUDGET THAT. INVESTS IN AND
KEEPS ALL CALIFORNIANS ON A
SUSTAINABLE PATH- TOWARDS
RECOVERY. AND GROWTH SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK SO. BEFORE
I CALL ON- MEMBERS IN OBVIOUSLY
AND IF YOU HAVE QUESTIONS FOR
EARLY OR DO YOU UP I WILL
CALLING YOU. ON MR PANIC I'M
QUESTIONING YOU USE THAT LAID
OUT THAT. THE LA O'S RESTAURANT
REVENUE ESTIMATES R. EIGHT
BILLION HIRED IN THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCES THAT WERE CONTAINED
IN THE MAY REVISE AND THAT'S
PARTIALLY DUE TO THE FACT OF
SOME REVENUES THAT CAME IN
SUBSEQUENT TO THAT. I MEAN AND-
SO I- OUT WHAT I'D LIKE YOU TO
ELABORATE ON IS- DID JUST MOVE
THOSE REVENUES THAT CAME IN BUT
ALSO. YOU THIS IS ALWAYS A BIG
DEPARTMENT FINANCE OF COURSE
DOES FOR CASTELLI- DOES
FORECAST BUT THE LEGISLATURE
HAS. RELIED ON THE LA- FOR THIS
FORECAST BECAUSE WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED THAT YOUR FORECASTS
FORECASTS HAVE BEEN A LITTLE
MORE ACCURATE THEN IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF YEARS AND SO IF YOU-
WOULDN'T MIND COMING IN ON THAT
YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY- WE- IS THAT
PORTION OF THE ARCHITECTURE IS
VERY IMPORTANT SO THAT. WE KNOW
THAT WE ARE BEING RESPONSIBLE
AS WE HAVE. DESCRIBED AND WE
INTEND TO BE SIR GO AHEAD. YES
OKAY THAT'S- AND IMPORTING
QUESTION MADAM CHAIR- AND I
WILL SAY THAT WE DID DO OUR YOU
KNOW OUR LEVEL BEST TO MAKE OUR
BEST GUESS ESTIMATE ON THE
REVENUE THEN OF COURSE OUR
REVENUES COULD JUST BECAUSE
THEY'VE BEEN- YOU KNOW- CLOSER
TO THE ACTUAL THAN SOME RECENT
YEARS THAT DOESN'T MEAN- THEY
ALWAYS WILL BE BUT ACCORDING TO
OUR- SCENARIO ANALYSIS. WE
THINK WE'RE AT ABOUT THE
FIFTIETH PERCENTILE POTENTIAL
OUTCOME WHICH MEANS ALTHOUGH
OUR REVENUES COULD ESTIMATE
COULD PROVE TO BE TOO HIGH THEY
COULD ALSO PROVE TO BE TOO LOW
RELATIVE TO THE ACTUAL RESULTS-
ONE REASON- SEVERAL REASONS
THAT WE FEEL LIKE. CONTINUATION
OF RELATIVELY STRONG REVENUE
GROWTH IS LIKELY REFLECTS- THAT
THE FOLLOWING CONDITIONS THE
FIRST IS THAT- THE CONSENSUS OF
ECONOISTS AT THIS TIME IS THAT
THE- ECONOMY IS POISED TO GROW
AT ITS FASTEST CLIP IN THE PAST
FORTY YEARS- IN ADDITION NOW
THE ECONOMY IS STILL
EXPERIENCING CONSIDERABLE
ASSISTANCE FROM- FEDERAL FISCAL
IMPORTS COMING THROUGH OUR
SYSTEM SO THAT'S GONNA- ADDED
BOOST TO GDP GROWTH- FEDERAL
RESERVE OFFICIALS HAVE
EXPRESSED COMMITMENT TO AN
ACCOMMODATIVE MONETARY POLICY
WHICH IS REFLECTED IN THE LOW
INTEREST RATE ENVIRONMENT WHICH
IS USUALLY CONDUCIVE TO
ECONOMIC GROWTH. BROADLY
SPEAKING. AND THEN YOU KNOW
RELATED TO THAT THE FINAL POINT
IS THAT AT THEIR PRICES REMAIN
HIGH AND- WITH HIGH STOCK
PRICES AND HOME VALUES YOU KNOW
DOES GENERATE. CONSIDERABLE
PERSONAL INCOME TAX REVENUES IN
PARTICULAR FOR THE STATE AND SO.
WELL THAT PARTICULAR ELEMENT IS
PUT IS SUBJECT TO A LOT OF
UNCERTAINTY AT LEAST FOR THE
UPCOMING BUDGET YEAR WE THINK
THAT THE BEST. YES IN OUR IN
OUR- WORLD VIEW IS THAT THE
CONTINUED STRONG GROWTH OF
REVENUES IS MORE LIKELY THAN
NOT- AND SO- YOU KNOW THAT THAT
SPEAKS TO WHY OUR REVENUES WERE
PROBABLY YOU KNOW IN THE RANGE
OF FOUR BILLION HIGHER THAN
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE AROUND
THE TIME OF THE MAY REVISION
AND THEN. AS YOU MENTIONED- IN
APRIL AND MAY TAX COLLECTIONS
CONTINUE TO SURPASS THE EARLIER
ESTIMATE AND WE'RE NOT
REFLECTED IN OUR- FORECAST AND-
THEREFORE YOU COULD ADD THOSE
TO THE TO THE MIX IN THAT LIST
THE REVENUE ESTIMATES BEST
IMAGE BY. ANOTHER THREE POINT
NINE BILLION SO WHEN YOU ADD
THE FOUR BILLION IN THE THREE
POINT NINE THAT'S WHERE YOU'RE
GETTING TO THE EIGHT BILLION
HIGHER REVENUES. I APPRECIATE
THAT EXPLANATION- ME SEE IF I
HAD ANOTHER QUESTION HI YOU
ALSO MENTIONED- BE A CHRISTIAN
THAT WAS BUILT IN FOR OUR
SCHOOLS IN RELATIONSHIP TO PROP
NINETY EIGHT COULD YOU JUST
ELABORATE ON THAT A LITTLE MORE.
SURE YOU KNOW WE OFTEN THINK-
THE BUDGET IN AND KIND OF TWO
SIDES OF THE HOUSE WANTED THE
NON NINETY EIGHT SIDE AND THEN
THE PROPOSITION NINETY EIGHT
SIDE. AND SO AS A BUDGET WITHIN
THE BUDGET THE PROPOSITION
NINETY EIGHT- OVERALL FUNDING
LEVEL- INCLUDE THIS YEAR A
SIGNIFICANT- ALLOCATION TO ONE
TIME SPENDING. AND SO WITH THAT
ONE TIME SPENDING- I'M SORRY IF
THE IF THE GUARANTEE WERE TO GO
DOWN IN A SUBSEQUENT YEAR THAT
ONE TIME SPENDING WOULD NOT BE
BAKED INTO THE- SCHOOL DISTRICT
BUDGETS AND WOULD RESULT AND-
YOU KNOW LESS- FISCAL PRESSURE
FOR SCHOOLS AND- AND OVERALL
PROP NINETY EIGHT- BUDGET AS A
RESULT. OF THAT THE SUBSTANTIAL
ALLOCATION TO ONE TIME- I DON'T
KNOW PERHAPS MY COLLEAGUE EDGAR
CABRAL WOULD WANT TO SUPPLEMENT
WHAT I'M SAYING WITH SOME WITH
SOME. YOU KNOW HELPFUL
ADDITIONAL DETAILS. GREAT.
ROSLYN'S GLOWING FROM WITHIN I
THINK I WAS JUST NOT A GOOD DAY
THE PROPOSITION NINETY RESERVE-
WHAT INCREASE TO- A FIVE POINT
THREE BILLION DOLLARS IN THE IN
THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE THAT'S
A REFLECTION OF THE ADDITIONAL-
ROMANISM HIGHER MINIMUM
GUARANTEE THAT'S- REQUIRED-
UNDER UNDER THE- CONSTITUTION
REQUIREMENTS OF THE RESEARCH.
ARM IN ADDITION BECAUSE THE
LEGISLATURE IS MAKING A LARGE
DEPOSIT IN THIS BUDGET IT WOULD
BE A THREE POINT ONE BILLION
DOLLAR DEPOSIT. IN THE BUDGET
YEAR IN ADDITION THERE IS A
VARIETY OF ONE TIME I'M
SPENDING THERE IS A VERY HARD
QUESTION IN THIS. IN THIS
BUDGET- WHICH MEANS THAT WE'RE
REVENUES TO DECLINE NEXT YEAR-
THE NEED FOR REDUCTIONS OF ARMS
YOU ARE I'M GOING TO TALK
EXCUSE PROGRAMS WHICH WOULD BE
UNLIKELY UNLESS IT WAS A VERY
VERY. LARGE- WE'RE LISTENING
ROOMS. GREAT THANK YOU. I AND-
BEFORE I TO CALL SIZE WANT TO
GET AN EXPRESS MY THANKS. TO
THE LA- FOR. THE EXCELLENT WORK
DID YOU THE ANNEX EXCELLENT
ANALYSIS THAT YOU HAVE BEEN
PROVIDING US. THAT THE
LEGISLATURE BOTH HOUSES HAVE.
RELIED ON A GREAT DEAL THIS
YEAR IN TERMS OF STRUCTURING
THIS AND WE REALLY DO
APPRECIATE. THAT DOES THAT
REVIEW AND ANALYSIS. SO SENATOR
NIELSEN THEN SENATOR DOLLY. AND
I THINK I SAW ANOTHER HAND UP
BUT OFTEN SECOND GO AHEAD
SENATOR NELSON- DIRECTED TO-
THE ANALYST STATIC. BUT MUCH
BETTER OVER THE YEARS. YOUR
FINANCIAL PROJECTIONS OF THE
ANALYSTS HAVE BEEN FAR MORE
CLOSE TO THE POINT THEN
GOVERNORS. I UNDERSTAND THAT
AND THAT IS REALLY NOT THE
POINT THAT I'M TRYING TO DO
WELL ON OTHER THAN THE FACT
THAT WE PUT A LOT OF
CREDIBILITY IN THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST. IT APPEARS TO ME. THAT
WE'RE CONTINUING. FROM TWELVE
BILLION AND SOLUTIONS FROM LAST
YEAR. AND WE'VE DONE THAT. OUR
CONTINUED TO BORROW. SOME THREE
BILLION DOES THAT MAKE A LOT OF
SENSE TO BE CONTINUING THAT AND
AS WELL THE GOVERNOR'S
EMERGENCY AUTHORITY I LIKE TO
GET INTO THAT IN GREATER DEPTH
TWO. BUT I PARTICULARLY THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE THAT
BORROWING WHILE WE'RE
INCREASING SPENDING VERY
SUBSTANTIALLY. IN THE BUDGET DO
YOU VIEW THAT AS THE MOST
PRUDENT APPROACH FOR THE
LEGISLATURE. WELL SENATOR NEIL
FINN- YOU KNOW I THINK WHAT
YOU'RE- SPEAKING TO IS REALLY.
A AN IMPORTANT QUESTION OF
TRADEOFFS AND RISK TOLERANCE AT
THE END OF THE DAY AND- WHILE
WE DID- MENTIONED THE
CONTINUATION OF. THE USES OF
THOSE RESOURCES IN THE CURRENT
BUDGET I WOULD- YOU KNOW I
WOULD NOTE THAT THE- YOU KNOW
THE LEGISLATIVE PACKAGES IS
COMPLYING WITH THE PROPOSITION
TWO REQUIREMENTS AND
INCREASING- THE RAINY DAY FUND
DEPOSIT. AND IT DOES DO SOME
OTHER THINGS THAT WE DIDN'T
MENTIONS THAT THE PREVIOUSLY
SUCH AS THE- FUNDING INTO THE
SAFETY NET RESERVE- THE
PREPAYMENT OF. OF BONDED DEBT
SERVICE AND THEN- ALSO THE PAY
DOWN THE FULL PAY DOWN OF THOSE
SCHOOL DEFERRAL. AND SO I THINK
WHAT WHERE THAT LEAVES US IS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE HAD YOU
KNOW AT THIS POINT THE WRITTEN
THERE ARE SUBSTANTIAL RESERVES
COMPARED TO- TWENTY YEARS AGO
OR BEFORE THE GREAT RECESSION
AND SO THAT'S ONE IMPORTANT-
CREDITS TO START WITH BUT THEN
I GUESS YOU KNOW ULTIMATELY. IT
WILL BE UP FOR THE LEGISLATURE
TO. BALANCE THE TRADEOFFS AND
ASSESS ITS RISK TOLERANCE FOR-
TO KIND OF OPPOSING TENSIONS
WANTED TO PREPARE FOR THE NEXT
DOWNTURN BY YOU KNOW
REPLENISHING EVEN MORE RESERVES
ARE USING A LOT OF
DISCRETIONARY RESERVES FOR-
REPLENISH THEIR BUILDING
RESERVES PURSES- USING THE
SUBSTANTIAL AMOUNT OF RESOURCES
THAT HAD THAT HAND TO ADDRESS
SOME OF ITS PRIORITIES AT THIS
TIME THEN YOU COULD. MAKE A
CASE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF IT
BUT- YOU KNOW IF IT TURNS OUT
THAT WE DON'T HAVE A DOWNTURN
IN THE YOU KNOW NEXT FEW YEARS
THAT COULD- PROVED TO BE
SOMEWHAT OF A MISSED
OPPORTUNITY IF THERE ARE
LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES THAT.
WARRANTS ATTENTION AT THIS TIME
AND SO I THINK THE DISCUSSION
YOU'RE HAVING TODAY IS REALLY
ABOUT THOSE COMPETING ARE
PRIORITIES AND WHERE ARE YOU-
ULTIMATELY RANK THEM AND HOW
HOW ARE YOU- AND INCORPORATE
THAT INTO. YOUR OVERALL RISK
TOLERANCE. WELL THE CONCERN I
HAVE IS ALWAYS BETTER BUILDING-
THAT WE DO THINGS THAT BUILD
THE BASE AND WE'RE CONTINUING
TO BORROW AND IN ADDITION HERE
WE ARE CONTINUING TO PROCEED TO
THE GOVERNOR THESE ARE
EMERGENCY STARTING XI JEALOUSLY
SEEMS TO GUARD THOSE. YEAH THAT
MADE A LOT OF SENSE SOME TIME
AGO TO ME GIVING THE GOVERNOR
THOSE EMERGENCY AUTHORITIES.
BUT GOVERNORS PLURAL HAVE BEEN
VERY JEALOUSLY PROTECTING THAT
THORGY. WHICH YOU SEARCH THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE IT GIVES THE
GOVERNOR THE AUTHORITY THAT I
DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD HAVE
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THE GOVERNORS
HAVE BEEN ABUSING. THAT
EMERGENCY AUTHORITY TO EXERCISE
THEIR OWN PRIORITIES AND
CIRCUMVENT THE LEGISLATURE AND
WE THE LEGISLATURE THERE ARE TO
BE DAMAGE FOR THAT WE HAVE
FACILITATED. THE SEATING OF OUR
CITIZENS. THE OPPORTUNITY TO
INPUT THE BUDGET. AT AGAIN I
JUST THINK THAT WE SHOULD BE
WAXING CAUTIOUS AS WE PROCEED
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
DOLLY HAD TO GO TO THE EQUALITY
OR THE ENVIRONMENT QUALITY
COMMITTEE SO- WILL SAVE HIS-
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FOR
LATER- LET'S SEE IF THERE'S
ANYONE. ELSE WHO WANTS TO ASK
THAT- YOU OR DO YOU OFFER
QUESTION BEFORE WE GO TO THE
PUBLIC COMMENT. ALL RIGHT GINO
MIKE'S UP- WE ARE. SO NOW WE
WILL MOVE INTO THE PERIOD WHERE
ANYONE WANTS TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT REGARDING OUR BILL THAT
WE'RE TAKING UP TODAY EIGHTY
ONE TWENTY EIGHT- AS A REMINDER
OUR PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8152 THE ACCESS CODE IS.
SEVEN EIGHT TWO ZERO ZERO EIGHT
FOUR- I WILL ASK THE- MODERATOR
GIVE ME THE- WHO'S IN THE QUEUE
THE NUMBER IN THE QUEUE IN A
FEW MINUTES BUT- FIRST I'M
GONNA GO TO THE GALLERY AND
LET'S SEE IF THERE'S ANY
WITNESSES HERE I HAD SEEN
SOMEONE BUT THEY DON'T LOOK TO
BE PRESENT NOW. SO THERE'S NO
ONE IN THE ROOM WANTS TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT LET ME
LOOK AT THE OVERFLOW ROOM NO
ONE THERE SO- WE WILL GO TO BE
TELECONFERENCE SERVICE-
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PLEASE
PROMPT THE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT AND RIGHT BEFORE YOU
HAVE THEM BEGIN IF YOU COULD
TELL ME THE NUMBER IN THE
QUEUE. I WOULD APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE LOOKS LIKE ABOUT
TEN IN Q. OKAY AND I HAVE NOT
GIVEN INSTRUCTIONS HOW TO GET A
FEW MORE- LEADS DON'T YOU WISH
THE- PUBLIC COMMENT ON AB ONE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
I'M AT T. OPERATOR WILL GIVE
YOUR LINE NUMBER OFFLINE. AND
THEN PLACE YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. AND YEAHWE'RE
PROBABLY PUSHING TWENTY NOW
MADAM CHAIR. GREAT IDEA WE'LL
GO TOO LONG- SKEWS ME ONE
THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING LINDA AWAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY WE WANT TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE FOR TODAY'S ACTION
PARTICULARLY WANT TO EXPRESS
SUPPORT FOR VARIOUS HEALTH
EQUITY PROPOSAL. TO ELIMINATE
THE MEDI CAL ASSET LIMITS
EXPAND MEDI CAL ALL IN ELIGIBLE
ADULTS FIFTY PLUS AS WELL AS
INVESTMENT IN CAL WORKS GRANT
AND ELIGIBILITY PROCESS
STREAMLINING WE APPRECIATE.
THAT FOOD FOR ALL PROPOSAL AND
RESTORATION OF SFI GRANTS AND
LOOK FORWARD TO FULL
RESTORATION IN THE FUTURE WE
APPRECIATE THE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE IN DOCUMENTS TO HELP
PROTECT TENANTS FROM EVICTION
STRONGLY SUPPORT THE END. OF
THE BOOK AND MAKING CRIMINAL.
AND TRAFFIC. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND IT'S WITH THE LINE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MICHAEL PIMENTEL EXACTLY
DIRECTOR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TRANSIT ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING EIGHTY FIVE
TRANSIT AND RAIL AGENCIES
ACROSS HER STATE ANT TO START
BY THANKING THE LEGISLATION THE
ADMINISTRATION FOR GRANTING A
BOLD AND TRANSFORMATIONAL
BUDGET THAT WILL ALLOW US TO
BUILD BACK BETTER FROM THE
PANDEMIC. IN PARTICULAR VOICING
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR THE
PROPOSED SUPPLEMENTAL
INVESTMENT OF THREE BILLION
DOLLARS IN TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AS WELL AS FOR
THE THREE POINT NINE BILLION
DOLLARS PROPOSED FOR YOUR
MISSION VEHICLES AND RELATED
INFRASTRUCTURE. FINALLY ON
VOICING OUR SUPPORT FOR THE
CONTINUATION AND EXPANSION OF
STATUTORY LEAVE FOR TRANSIT
AGENCIES URGING YOU TO EXTEND
THAT RELIEF THROUGH FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR AT
NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION WE WOULD URGE
THE LEGISLATURE TO APPROVE THE
FULL OF INVESTMENTS IN
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
IN THE MAY REVIVE AND TO
MAINTAIN THE SPECIFIC
PROGRAMMATIC ALLOCATION
BENEFITING PUBLIC TRANSIT IN
THE TERROR MISSION VEHICLE AND
READ RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE
LINE ITEM AGAIN PROPOSED MAY
REQUIRE. MORE DETAILS ARE
INCLUDED IN OUR LETTER TO
LEADERSHIP AND COMMITTEE DATED
MAY. TWENTY SIXTH THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU.
MODERATOR THANK YOU ONE THIRTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI ERIN
AT THE APPELLATE ADVOCATE THANK
YOU FOR YOUR DILIGENT WORK ON
THIS PROJECT WE APPRECIATE THE
EFFORTS OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
LEADERSHIP AND STAFF IN THE
ADMINISTRATION BACK IN
EDUCATION BUT DID THAT BUT I
DID EQUITIES AND LAID THE
GROUNDWORK FOR FULL
TRANSFORMATION WE APPRECIATE A
SUBSTANTIAL INVESTMENT
COMMUNITY POOL AND ASK YOU NOT
TO FORGET THAT THE FOUR PILLARS
OF COMMUNITY SCHOOL INCLUDING
FAMILY COMMUNITY ENGAGEMENT.
AND COLLABORATIVE LEADERSHIP
AND PRACTICES ARE FOUNDATIONAL
TO THE PROGRAM COMMUNITY
SCHOOLS ARE MORE THAN SERVICE
PROVIDERS THEY MUST EMPHASIZE
SYSTEM TRANSFORMATION I THANK
WE ASK YOU TO MAKE
COLLABORATIVE PLANNING AND
DECISION MAKING PARENTS
STUDENTS TEACHERS AND STAFF A
PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS. THE
AUTHORITY TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE TO ENSURE THAT NEW
AND EXISTING COMMUNITY
CORPORATE CAPACITY BUILDING
SUPPORT TO DEVELOP SUSTAINABLE
PROGRAMS. QUICKLY FIFTY
ADDITIONAL FUNDING PROVIDED
FRIENDSHIP LOOKING AT PEOPLE
AND SUPPORT KIND OF FUNDING TO
INCREASE STAFFING ALTHOUGH WE
PREFER TO BE THE INCREASE OF
THE OFFENSE AND THEN GO TO THE
CONCENTRATION GRANT WE ALSO
SUPPORT A SIGNIFICANT
INVESTMENT IN EDUCATOR TRAINING
AND PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT
BANNON DIVERSIFY THE TEACHER
PIPELINE. AND LASTLY WE OPPOSE
THE SPENDING THE REQUIREMENT
THAT 25% OF WILLIAM SETTLEMENT
I INSPECTIONS BY COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT. ANNOUNCED AND
WE ASK YOU NOT TO LEAVE THIS
REQUIREMENT. THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERING OUR RECOMMENDATIONS.
THANK YOU. NEXT A LINE YEAR
YOUR OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MADAM CHAIRMAN PLAN TAYLOR ON
BEHALF OF THE CAL AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL OFFICERS ASSOCIATION.
AS BUDGET NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE
WE RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
EXPAND AB ANY CLEAN AIR PROGRAM
INCLUDES A COLUMN WHEREIN
LOCALLY B. NINE TWENTY THREE
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS. SECONDLY IN
LIGHT OF THE BUDGET SURPLUS WE
ASK YOU TO FURTHER PRIORITIZE
INCENTIVE FUNDING FOR THE
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN AND FARMER
CLEAN AIR PROGRAMS. AND LAST
WELL WE APPRECIATE THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED FIFTY
MILLION FOR AIR DISTRICT.
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
IMPLEMENTATION IT DOES NOT
COVER CURRENT COSTS FOR ACCOUNT
FOR NEW COMMUNITIES ADDED TO
THIS IMPORTANT STATE MANDATED
PROGRAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING TURN MEMBERS THIS
IS ROSS BARKLEY ON BEHALF OF
SOUTH COAST AT&T THE SOUTH
COAST STATES IN THE NORTH
CHALLENGES ARE GUESSING AIR
POLLUTION TOXIC ESPECIALLY IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES.
SIGNIFICANT SUSTAINABLE CENTERS
FUNDING IT'S CRITICAL FOR MAIN
HEALTH BASED AIR QUALITY
STANDARDS AND SHE EVEN SORELY
NEED NEAR TERM EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS WE SUPPORT FUNDING
FOR YOUR PLATE PEOPLE TRUCKS
WITH NEAR ZERO EMISSION TRUCKS
ARE LOWER COSTS OF CREDIT IN
YOUR EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS.
THAT'S WHAT WE CAME IN WITH
LONGER TIMELINES NEEDED. CHEAP
MASS APPOINTMENT OF YOUR
AMBITION. WE ALSO HAVE TO USE A-
EIGHTY EIGHT WE ARE. THIS YEAR
EXPECT NOW PROVIDES PROGRAMS
ABILITY INCOME STAY
IMPLANTATION PLANT HOME
INSURANCE PRIVATE INVESTING
TECHNOLOGY. WE ALSO APPRECIATE
BABY TO CONTEMPORARY DISTRICTS
ARE RAFTING CREEK INCENTIVE
FUNDING TO PRACTICE YOUR GERMAN
JUST MISSION REDUCTIONS.
INCREASE IN PLANTATION FUNNY
COVER ACTUAL COSTS HER FAMILY
WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO RELEASE
FUNDING FOR STUFF THAT THEY CAN
BE FROM FEDERAL. AID FUNDS TO
SUPPORT. AFRICAN CUTTING AIR
POLLUTION THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS DIANA DOUGLAS WOULD
HELP THAT CALIFORNIA WE
APPRECIATE THE LEGISLATURE'S
WORK ON THE BUDGET HEALTH
ACTIVE SUPPORT THE FOLLOWING
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS ON HEALTH
FOR ALL TO EXPAND MEDICAID OUT
THE AGE. IN THE LIMITING THE
MEDIC HOW AT THAT TIME CREATING
THE HEALTH EQUITY FUND
ESTABLISHING THE OFFICE OF
HEALTHCARE PORTABILITY AND WE
ALSO APPRECIATE THE DIRECTION
TO COVERED CALIFORNIA TO
DEVELOP A PORTABILITY OPTIONS.
ON COST SHARING THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. NINE FOURTEEN
YOU ARE OPEN THANK YOU MARTY
EMOTO- FAMILY MEMBER OF A
PERSON WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES ALSO HE CAN
CALIFORNIA DISABILITY YOUR
COMMUNITY ACTION NETWORK I JUST
WANT TO THANK- BILL THE
COMMITTEE BOARD- AND WE SUPPORT
THE FORWARD LOOKING BUDGET AND
IT REFLECTS ALLTHE PENT UP
PRIORITIES THAT WE HAVE ALL
WANTED TO SEE HAPPEN FINALLY SO
AGAIN. APPRECIATE THAT JUST
THREE QUICK POINTS SUPPORT
ESPECIALLY THE RESTORATION OF
THE SS P. GRANT TO THE LEVEL
WAS UP PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND
NINE- ALSO SUPPORT THE BUDGET
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THAT WAS
A RELEASE ON FRIDAY ON THE
FUNDING FOR THE REGIONAL CENTER
PROVIDER RATE STUDY THAT LINKS-
GREAT REFORM TO PERSON CENTRED
OUTCOMES WE THINK THE BUDGET
STAFF IN THE ALLEY- DID A
TREMENDOUS JOB AND LISTENING TO
ADVOCATE. AND LASTLY JUST WANNA
ALSO PROOF THAT THE LEGISLATURE
A DOCTOR HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED SERVICES AT B. S.
SPENDING PLAN SOMETIMES
REFERRED AS ARPA THE AMERICAN
RECOVERY PLAN ACT. AS RELEASED
BY THE NEWS AMID MINISTRATION
ON JUNE THIRD WE THINK THAT
APPROACH REALLY REFLECTS THE
WHOLE PERSON AND PERSON CENTRED
OUTCOMES- THAT ADDRESS SHOULD
ADDRESS ISSUES OF EQUITY AND
UNMET NEED AND ACTUALLY IT'S
CRITICAL TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
THE RATE STUDY AGAIN THANK ALL
OF YOU FOR DOING SUCH A
TREMENDOUS. JOB FOR ALL OF US
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. FIVE
THIRTY THREE THIRTY ME THIRTY
TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. AMERICAN
MORNING AND MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- I NEED TO TELL YOU CAN
CALL ME IN A RECORD SETTING THE
ADVANCEMENT PROJECT CALIFORNIA-
CALLING INSTEAD I THANK
EVERYONE FOR THE GREAT WORK
MEMBERS STAFF DEPARTMENT
FINANCE AND ALSO BE ELLIE L.
GREAT WORK I'M FOCUSING ON
COUNTERING EQUITY. AND BUDGET-
THE TECHNICALLY LOOKING AT-
ALLOCATING FUNDING FOR THE
OFFICE OF RACIAL EQUITY AND
PEOPLE THAT WORK AT THE
SEVENTEEN BY SENATOR PIANE-
UNDER IT YOU CAN PAINT ORIENTED
COUNCIL COURT MEETING BE
PERFECT STRATEGIES FOR
ADVANCING RACIAL EQUITY ACROSS.
STATE AGENCIES. GOOD WORK THAT
WE CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE
HEALTH WELL BEING OUR MOTOR.
BOTTOM OKAY. AND IT'S SUCH A
PROPOSAL WITH THAT OTHER
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS CURRENTLY
CREEK. AND EXISTING PROPERTY
DAMAGES BY ESTABLISHING A LONG
TERM INFRASTRUCTURE. THANK YOU
SO MUCH WE LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO WORK TOGETHER TO
FIND THESE EFFORTS THAT
CULTIVATE EQUITY IMPROVED ALL
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
AND HAVE A GREAT REST OF YOUR
MORNING. THANK YOU. FINAL FINAL
LEVIN YOU ARE OPEN. YOU KNOW
LIKE A CHILDCARE LONGSTANDING
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ON THE
LEGISLATURE'S BRIDGE STRONG
SUPPORT FOR CHILDCARE AND YOUR
BUDGET WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THE
INCREASE IN THE NUMBER OF CHILD
CARE SLOTS AND DEFINE ALL CHILD
CARE PROGRAM THE EIGHTY FIFTH
PERCENTILE OF THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ARAMARK. WE URGE THE
LEGISLATURE TO INCLUDE TRAILING
THE LANGUAGE THAT WE ALL FAMILY
FEES REGARDLESS. OF SHELTERING
THREE QUARTERS. ADDITIONALLY WE
ARE THE IMMEDIATE FUTURE OF
CARE IN ADDITION GRAHAM.
FEDERAL GRANTS HAS.
REQUIREMENTS TO SUPPORT PRIVATE
AND PUBLICLY FUNDED CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS. WE HAD THE MEDICAL
COLLEGE TRAVEL THE LANGUAGE ON
THESE GRANTS TO COMPLY WITH
FEDERAL LAW. FINALLY REGARDING
HE CAKE WE URGE OUR ROBOT THANK
YOU VERY THE COLDER POCKETS
OVER THE NEXT YEAR. TO CREATE A
TRULY UNIVERSAL MAKES DELIVERY
MODEL THAT THANK ME FOR THE
NEEDS OF FAMILIES CHILDREN AND
PROVIDERS AND THAT MINIMIZE.
THE NEGATIVE IMPACT OF THE
CHILD. WE HAD COMMITTED
PROPOSED PEOPLE AT THE LANGUAGE
THAT. THE CARD THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. FINE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS KEVIN
AT THE HELM OF THE COALITION
CALIFORNIA WEAPON
RECOMMENDATIONS AND FINALLY WE
HAVE A NICE BUDGET WE
APPRECIATE IT WE JUST WANT TO
MENTION- THANK YOU FOR THE
COWBOYS INCREASES THE SITE
INCLUDES ACCESS TO JUSTICE. AND
CHOKE HIM WE WANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THIS BUDGET STILL-
BEGINNING SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT EVERY YEAR THEY TAKE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS OUT OF THE
MOUNTAINS OKAY OUR CHILDREN
THREE GIVE IT TO BUT THE CALL
CONTRIBUTION TO THE GENERAL
FUND. THIS YEAR THE BUDGET
TAKES ABOUT ONE TO TWO BILLION
DOLLARS- AWAY FROM GYPSUM
PANELS IN SOME JOB WORKED THEN
USES IT TO SUPPLEMENT THE
BUDGET MEANWHILE CHILDREN ON
CAL WORKS OR LIVING IN POVERTY
THE AVERAGE GRAND
NOTWITHSTANDING THE FIVE POINT
3% INCREASE. IS STILL SEVEN
TWENTY THREE A MONTH FOR A
FAMILY OF THREE THAT'S THE
AVERAGE GRAND THEN WE WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THE ONE BILLION TO
TWO BILLION DOLLARS IF YOU'RE
NOT GOING TO GIVE THE FULL
COUNT WALKS ISSUED THE SPECIAL
FORM THAT COULD BE USED FOR CAL
WORKS IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. MY TWENTY FIVE YEAR
ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING THANK
YOU SENATOR SKINNER AN
HONORABLE MEMBER I THINK. MY
NAME IS ALEXIS FOLEY
LEGISLATIVE INTERN WITH THE
CHILD SUPPORT DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION THE STA I AM
CALLING TO EXPRESS THE FDA'S
SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET PLAN THE
BUDGET PRIORITIZES SERVICES TO
THOSE IN GREATEST NEED
INCLUDING THE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES SERVED BY THE CHILD
SUPPORT PROGRAM. THE FDA IS
BELIEVED TO BE A COMMITMENT TO
LOCAL CHILD SUPPORT AGENCIES IS
REFLECTED IN THE INCREASED
FUNDING FOR THE. TWENTY NINE
MOST UNDERFUNDED COUNTY. THE
TICKET FUNDING RESEARCH PRIOR
YEAR CASH TO THE- AND ITS
COUNTY CLOSER TO EQUITY AFTER
MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS OF BLACK
BINDING. THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. FINE TWENTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND HONORABLE
MEMBERS AMY HINES CYCLIC
WILDCAT CONSULTING REPRESENTING
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY LAND
TRUST NETWORK THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE VISIONARY FUNDING FOR
THE FORECLOSURE INTERVENTION
HOUSING PRESERVATION PROGRAM.
THAT FIVE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS WILL GREATLY ASSIST
CALIFORNIANS AFTER THE
MORATORIUM IS LIFTED AND WE
GREATLY APPRECIATE YOUR
CONSTANT FOCUS ON EQUITY IN
THIS BUDGET AND ALLEVIATING THE
PAIN OF WORKING CLASS FOLKS
THINK. THANK YOU. NINE THIRTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MY
THIRTY SEVEN CAN YOU HEAR IT.
YES GOOD MORNING ANDREA SAN
MIGUEL CALLING FROM PLANNED
PARENTHOOD AFFILIATES IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE VERY GLAD
TO SEE THE LEGISLATURE VERSION
OF THE BUDGET WE USE SOMETHING
CALLED THIRTY TWO AT TRAILER
BILL LANGUAGE TO ADDRESS THE
NEED FOR EQUITABLE ACCESS. IN
MEDIC HELP FOR TELEHEALTH JUST
WANT TO MAKE THE POINT THAT YOU
KNOW CALIFORNIANS SHOULD- HAVE
THE SAME ACCESS TO USING
TELEHEALTH SERVICES WHETHER OR
NOT THEY HAD MEDIC HOW WERE
THEY HAVE PRIVATE INSURANCE AND
THIS IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
FOR REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
SERVICES. AND WE'RE SO GLAD
THAT THAT ON THE CHAIR AND
FRONTIER AND THEN COMMITTEE
HERE TODAY THE LEGISLATURE. FOR
MAKING A SAP ISSUE- MAKE SURE
THAT THE EQUITY IN TELE HEALTH
IS SOMETHING THAT IS INCLUDED
IN THE BUDGET WE ALSO STRONGLY
SUPPORT THE PLAN TO REMOVE THE
80% OF MEDICARE CAP ALLOWANCE
SERVICES THAT ARE PART OF A
BROADER. AGREEMENT WITH THE
WITH THE LEGISLATURE SO FAR-
THAT CAPPED A DRIVE DOWN THE
AMOUNT OF FUNDING THAT IS
AVAILABLE TO HELP CENTERS FOR
CORE SERVICES INCLUDING STI
TESTING WE APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
TO HELP SOLVE THE ISSUE- AND AS
WELL AS THE ONE TIME ASPECT OF
THAT PROPOSAL AND SO BOTH OF
THESE ITEMS ARE CRITICAL. HE
WOULD NOT HAVE ADEQUATE FUNDING
FOR PATIENT CARE AND BUT WE
JUST ARE SO EXCITED TO SEE THE
WHAT IS THAT YOU'RE TAKING A
STEP TODAY- WHICH ARE NOT JUST
THAT THE ELEMENTS OF THIS BILL
THAT ALSO AND A BROADER
AGREEMENT WITHIN SECURE HOUSES.
AND THANK YOU ALL SO MUCH FOR
YOUR WORK. THANK YOU. NINE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALAN ABBAS
REPRESENTING THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT I'M
CALLING TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR
ELEMENTS IN THE GOVERNOR'S MAY
REVISE THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
NOT YET FULLY EMBRACE.
INCLUDING EXPANDED FUNDING FOR
THE EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN
PROGRAM INCLUDING IN
IMPLEMENTATION FUNDING
REFLECTIVE OF ACTUAL COST
EIGHTY SIX SEVENTEEN INCENTIVE
PROGRAM RE AUTHORIZATION OF THE
CARL MOYER IN EIGHTY EIGHT
PROGRAM THE GOVERNORS THAT
PACKAGE AND AB. EIGHT THIRTY
SIX CLEAN AIR CENTER PROGRAM
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE
THIRTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS INTERCHANGE FROM
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
FOOD BANKS ONE THANK YOU THE
COMMITTEE THE STAFF THE
LEGISLATURE FOR BUILDING ON THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE FOR A
TRULY TRANSFORM THE BUDGET- A
FEW HIGHLIGHTS OF COURSE WE'RE
THRILLED TO SEE THAT MUCH
NEEDED INVESTMENT I CAN'T
UNDERPRIVILEGED AND AS WELL AS
CLIPPERS. PRODUCTS THE SCHOOL
MEALS ALL PACKAGE AGAIN WITH
THE GRATEFUL FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP OTHER AT FIFTY GRAND
RESTORATION FINALLY- THAT
COMMUNITY FEELS HEARD FOR THE
FIRST TIME IN YEARS REALLY-
LIFE SAVING INVESTMENTS- THE
FOOD FOR ALL AND ACCOMPLISH
IMMIGRANT EXPLOSON AS WELL AT
THE OTHER INVESTMENT ACCOUNT
QUESTION CAL WORKS- MEDICARE
HEALTH CHILD CARE THE FEED INTO
THAT TRAP MANLY. IN HUNGER AND
POVERTY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. MY TWENTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SURE
NUMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON
BEHALF OF THE CHIEF PROBATION
OFFICERS OF CALIFORNIA I'D LIKE
TO SEE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO
ESTABLISH A STATEWIDE PRE TRIAL
PROGRAM WITHOUT THE DEVELOPMENT
OF MORE NON FINANCIAL OPTIONS
THAT THE COURT TO FIND YOUR
STANDARD REASONABLY PROTECTING
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND ASSURING
RETURNED TO COURT AND PLEADED
IN THE HUMPHREY DECISION
CALIFORNIA WILL CONTINUE TO SEE
SOME PEOPLE REMAIN IN CUSTODY
PENDING TRIAL WILL RELY ON CASH
BAIL IN THE NIGHT OTHERWISE
HAVE BEEN FOUND SUITABLE FOR
NON FINANCIAL OPTIONS SUCH AS
PRE TRIAL PROGRAM ESTABLISHED
WITH PROBATION DEPARTMENT.
PRIOR TO HUNGARY AND THROUGH
THE CONTINUED IMPLEMENTATION OF
THAT DECISION WHERE THERE ARE
PROBLEMS PRE TRIAL PROGRAMS RUN
IN COLLABORATION WITH PROBATION
WE SEE CORTINA LIKE THE NON
FINANCIAL RELIEF OPTIONS FOR
THEM NOT PREVIOUSLY OR
CURRENTLY ARE ONLY RELEASED-
PRETTY MUCH A POSTING BAIL WE
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO COMMENT ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE. AND LOOK FORWARD. TO
MORE DISCUSSION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS- THIS
IS COULD BE PRESIDING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE OR REJECTING THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE THAT
THANK YOU AFTER INPATIENT
PROGRAM AND INTEGRATION AND IF
THEY CAN BE D. AS A PROPOSAL
WOULD HAVE ELIMINATED TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY. PSYCHIATRIC
TECHNICIANS IN THE STATE PRISON
SYSTEM- AFTER HAVING WORKED
OVER TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
THOUSAND HOURS OF OVERTIME THIS
YEAR- IS. THE REASON THAT
PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIAN POSITION
SHOULD BE ADDED NOT DETRACTED
FROM THE BUDGET SO WE ENCOURAGE
THE- LEGISLATURE TO CONTINUE TO
HOLD STRONG ON THE POSITION OF
REJECTING THIS PROPOSAL AS
NEGOTIATIONS CONTINUE SO ONCE
AGAIN THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR-
THIS REJECTION OF THE PROPOSAL.
THANK YOU. ONE FORTY TWO YOU
ARE OPEN. JAMIE MIDDLE HIGHLAND
HEADSTART CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS FOR YOUR
WORK ON THE BUDGET I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF NEARLY ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY I THANK RANKING
CALIFORNIA TURNING OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND CHILDREN
ANNUALLY AND THEIR FAMILIES I'M
PLAYING OVER TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND TEACHERS STATEWIDE
WE'RE CONTINUING TO
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST SUPPORT
FOR A SEPARATE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR PROCREATION IN THE
BUDGET. WE'RE GOING TO MAKE
SURE THE LOCAL PROGRAM TO
CONTINUE AND REACH MORE
CHILDREN AND EARLY HEAD START I
START MIGRATING PEOPLE HAD
STARRED IN HIGH TECH A THIRD
PARTY AND CANNOT EASILY SHIFT
THEIR FUNDING TO SERVE MY
THIRTY THREE YEAR OLD DURING
THE PEAK TRANSACTION THAT
INVOLVED IN THE APPLICATION OF
EARLY HEAD START GRANT FUNDING
AND APPROVAL PROCESS BY THE
FEDERAL OFFICE OF HEAD START.
WELL IN SHARING THE FACILITIES
MEET THE REQUIREMENTS YOUR
BABY'S TRAINING FOR TEACHERS
AND STAFF WE APPRECIATE SENATOR
MADE COMMENTS ABOUT MAKING SURE
THAT THE EXPANSION OF T. K.
THAT'S NOT HURT OTHER
PROVIDERS- IF YOU CAN MAKE SURE
THE WHOLE THIRTY BECAUSE THE
COURT PROGRAMS THEY NEED TO.
CONTINUE TO SERVE CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES DURING THE T. TAKE
ACTION AND NOT JUST THE HEAD
START PROGRAM BETTER ON THE
EIGHT THANK YOU THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND STAFF
SELECTING A TARGET. WILL BE
IMPACTED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FOR MY FORTY THREE PLEASE AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING- MADAM CHAIR THE
SENATE SPEAKING PURELY CALL ON
THE OF CHARLES ARE DREW OF
MEDICINE AND SCIENCE- THE ONLY
BLACK UNIVERSITY WEST OF TEXAS
WE ARE EXTREMELY EXCITED AND
STRONG SUPPORTER. OF THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR PROCREATION
PROCEED THROUGH THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA- FOR THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE MEDICAL
FACILITIES- OR THE FACILITY
THAT WILL HOUSE A MEDICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAM. THIS IS A
GAME CHANGER AS FAR AS WE SEE
IT IN IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE STATE CALIFORNIA CONTINUING
TO RECOGNIZE THAT CULTURALLY
COMPETENT HEALTHCARE MATTERS
BLACK AND BROWN TO PATIENT
MATTER- IF THE DEMOGRAPHICS OF.
THE UNIVERSITY'S EXISTING
MEDICAL EDUCATION PROGRAM THAT
IS JOINTLY OPERATED WITH UCLA
ANY INDICATION OF THE FUTURE
DEMOGRAPHIC. OF THIS NEW
MEDICAL SCHOOL. EACH INCOMING
CLASS. WILL INCREASE THE NUMBER
OF BLACK MEDICAL STUDENTS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BY OVER
30% AND THE NUMBER OF BLACK NET
MEDICAL GRADUATES. BY MORE THAN
20% AND SO- WE APPRECIATE YOUR
INVESTMENT INTO THIS INTO THE
DIRT- THE EDUCATION OF A
DIVERSE GROUP. OF FUTURE
MEDICAL GRADUATE AND WE
STRONGLY URGE YOUR SUPPORT. IN
KEEPING IT IMPLEMENTED THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS TIRING
THE WITH THE COUNTY PAPER HOP
RECORDS WITH THE AGE AND WE
WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
LEGISLATURE AND ADMINISTRATION
FOR HISTORIC BUDGET BACK NECK
AND BACK WITH ME TO GIVE ME A
PACKET FOR HOW I MISS A LOT OF
ITEMS I COULD MENTION BUT NOT
UNDER MY COMMENTS AROUND IT
SEVERAL KEY INVESTMENTS. WERE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE FUNDING FOR
THE PAPER HOW CONTINUING
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECT
INVESTMENTS IN YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INCLUDING THE
AUGMENTATION OF THE MENTAL
HEALTH STUDENT SERVICES BACK
IMMEDIATE INVESTMENT IN YOU
THINKING ABOUT HOW I DIDN'T
RETURN TO SCHOOL THAT FALL INTO
FINANCIAL INVESTMENT IN THE HIP
HOP WORK FORCE WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK THE LEGISLATURE
FOR THE REJECTION ON THE
LANTERN PATRICK SHORT ACT
CONTRACTED CONTINUATION BUT.
THE DEPARTMENT AT THE HOSPITAL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MY NAME IS GETTING
COBURN CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION OUR COMMUNITY BASED
PROGRAMS ARE CAPPED WITH
ENROLLMENT OF THE COUNCIL AND
OUR LOWEST INCOME FAMILIES WITH
ACCESS TO CHILD HEARING OTHERS.
NEEDED FAMILY SUPPORT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR PUTTING FORWARD
A BOLD PLAN FOR REIMBURSEMENT
RATE REFORM. BRING
REIMBURSEMENT RATE FOR
PROVIDERS THAT EXPANDING MY
CHILD CARE CAPACITY IN HIGH
NEED COMMUNITIES. CAPPING
FAMILY VISAS AND INCREASING
ELIGIBILITY FOR ALL. REALIZE
YOUR PRIORITY THANKFUL THAT
FURTHER EROSION OF THE CHILD
CARE WORKFORCE IN MY FAMILY
THAT. WE WOULD LIKE TO BRING
YOUR ATTENTION TO THE INCREASE
IN PLOT THERE MUST ALSO BE
IMMEDIATE ATTENTION FOR TRAILER
BILL MONEY FOR COMMUNITY
AGENCIES TO BEGIN IMMEDIATELY
WRAPPING UP FAMILY INVOLVEMENT.
THE INCREASE SLOTS WILL MORE
THAN TRIPLE THE EXISTING
CAPACITY OF COMMUNITY PROGRAMS.
FURTHER WE ASK FOR IMMEDIATE
ACTION TO SHORE UP FUNDING FOR
EXISTING FAMILY COMMUNITY
AGENCIES HAVE RECEIVED THEIR
TWENTY TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO
YEAR CONTRACT AND WE ARE
LOOKING AT AND MEDIA CONTROL
MEANTTHAT THOUSANDS OF THE
CENTRAL FAMILY. WE BELIEVE THAT
IF YOU INCREASE THE RATES AND
PROVIDE FUNDING FOR CONTRACTORS
TO RAMP UP. THEN WE WILL BE
ABLE TO ENROLL ANY NUMBER OF
WHAT WE MAKE AVAILABLE THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR INVESTMENT.
THANK YOU. I THIS WOULD BE A
GOOD TIME TO RE PROMPT ONE MORE
TIME IF YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO- MADAM CHAIRS
TO GET THE HEADS UP YOU HAVE
FIVE. IN Q. AT THIS POINT. AND
NOW SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD FORTY
SEVEN GREAT. MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS GINNY TO
STRONG GRIN ON MAIN A. R. P.
VOLUNTEER REPRESENTING OVER
THREE MILLION AARP MEMBERS IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR YOUR HARD WORK ON
DEVELOPING THIS BUDGET IS QUITE
EXCITING- A. R. P. SUPPORTS THE
INVESTMENT FOR SERVICES. AND
CARE GIVER PROPOSALS FROM BOTH
THE MAY REVISE AND THE HOME AND
COMMUNITY BASED SERVICES
SPENDING PLAN WE ALSO SUPPORT
THE LEGISLATOR SUBCOMMITTEE
REPORT- FROM EARLY JUNE AND
SPECIFICALLY BUT NOT LIMITED TO
THE INVESTMENTS IN THE CARE
GIVERS RESOURCE CENTER AGAIN WE
THANK YOU FOR ALL YOUR HARD
WORK AND CONTINUE AND URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT THE AGING AND CARE
GIVER COMMUNITY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. FORTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
JENNIFER MAILING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION A
CALIFORNIA COMEBACK WILL
LARGELY DEPEND ON THE ABILITY
OF WORKING PEOPLE TO RETURN TO
GOOD QUALITY STABLE JOBS WE
KNOW LITTLE LOW WAGE WORKERS
AND THE UNEMPLOYED WILL TAKE
LONGER TO RECOVER FROM THE
RECESSION AND WILL NEED THE
SUPPORT FROM THE EIGHT TO FIND
HIGH QUALITY BETTER WAGE JOB.
TO REBUILD THE ECONOMY. WHEN
INVESTING WORKFORCE AND
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT IT'S
CRITICAL THAT WE CONNECT FRIEND%
TO WELL DEFINED WORKFORCE
PROBLEM FOCUSED ON INITIATIVES
THAT HAVE A PROVEN TRACK RECORD
IN DEVELOPING CLEAR MECHANISMS.
FOR WORKERS TO PROVIDE INPUT ON
INDUSTRY NEEDS. AND THE QUALITY
OF AVAILABLE TRAINING PROGRAM.
WITH THAT WE PUBLISH IT THE
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE IS
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY MILLION
DOLLAR INVESTMENT TOWARDS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT. AS WELL
AS THE SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE FUND. AND AFTER
CONSIDERATION IN DEVELOPING A
SAFETY NET AND RAPID RESPONSE
FOR DISPLACED WORKERS. I'LL BE
OFF AT THE LEGISLATURE CONSIDER
CREATING A GRANT PROGRAM THAT
SUPPORTS DISPLACED WORKERS
PARTICULARLY HOSPITALITY. AND
SERVICE SECTOR WORKERS. I AND
THAT IT CRITICAL TO RECORD
DIFFERENT WORKERS. DURING PAST.
FIVE BY PROVIDING HAZARD PAY
FOR SOCIAL WORKERS. THANK YOU
AND REALLY APPRECIATE ALL YOUR
WORK ON THAT. THANK YOU. ONE
FIFTY EUROPE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS BEVERLY YOU ON BEHALF
OF P. W. WE APPRECIATE HAVE A
TREMENDOUS WORK ON THE BUDGET
AND YOUR LEADERSHIP. THANK YOU
TO YOU AND YOUR STAFF. OTHER
PROVISIONS ON THE PERMANENT
RESTORATION THE PHONE PERCENT
CUT RIGHT BACK WHICH IS LONG
OVERDUE. AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
OTHER BUDGET BILLS ON THEM LIKE
A FEATURES AGREEMENT
PARTICULARLY AROUND THE PACKAGE
TO IMPROVE THE GO SHE ASIANS AT
THE TABLE FOR ESSENTIAL FAMILY
I. WORKERS PREVENTING THE SIXTY
FIVE THIRTY FIVE COUGHLIN. 10%
OVER THREE YEARS WELL AN
ACCOMPLISHMENT THE COOK COUNTY
ON COUNTY HAPPILY BARKING GOOD
FAITH. I'M HAPPY TO YOU IN
PARTNERSHIP BETWEENA GUY
KNEELING B. W. WE'RE PLEASED TO
SEE THE IMPACT THAT THE CHILD
HERE SPECIFICALLY THE
ADDITIONAL HUNDRED THOUSAND
TRUCKERS BLOCKING REFORM
REIMBURSEMENT RATE. IN EIGHTY
FIFTH PERCENTILE THE TWENTY
EIGHTEEN REGIONAL MARKET RATE
SURVEY. THAT WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR SUPPORT. EIGHTEEN
POINT TWENTY EIGHT TODAY THANK
YOU. THANK ONE FIFTY ONE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. FIFTY ONE ARE YOU
MUTED. ONE FIFTY ONE ONE MORE
TIME PLEASE GO AHEAD. YOUR OPEN.
FIFTY ONE. THEY MIGHT BE HAVING
A PHONE ISSUE MOVE ALONG TO
LINE. FORTY EIGHT. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS PAMELA
GELLER'S REPRESENTING THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION. FIRST OF ALL LIKE TO
THINK ABOUT THE SURGICAL
INSURANCE SUPPORT EARLY
LEARNING AND CARE PROPOSAL. TO
PUT THE SAFETY NET ESPECIALLY
FOR CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
ELIGIBLE FOR HEAD START AND
STATE PRE SCHOOL PROGRAMS.
MICHAEL MY COMMENTS WITH HEAD
START CALIFORNIA AND THE
REQUEST FOR FIFTEEN FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS. IN AN EFFORT
TO SUPPORT ART PROGRAMS R. TWO
KT TRANSACTION CONTINUES. AND
ALSO I WOULD LIKE TO SUPPORT
THE EFFORTS OF THE LEGISLATURE
TO PAY DOWN THE FIRM'S. VERY
COSTLY IN THE LONG RUN AS
STATED BY MADAM CHAIR DURING
HER OPENING REMARKS. SH WE ALSO
APPRECIATE THE- SUPPORT FOR
FUNDING FOR COUNTY OPERATED
PROGRAMS THAT SERVE ANIMALS AT
PROMISE YOUTH. AND LASTLY WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR GRATITUDE
AND THANKS. FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
QUESTION WAS SUPPORTED THIS
YEAR WITH A POINT TO CONTINUING
THE DIALOGUE AND DISCUSSION
WITH YOU AS YOU REACH AGREEMENT
ON THE BUDGET. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. R. FIFTY ONE
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO READ
PROPERLY AT ONE ZERO WE COULD
NOT HEAR YOU AND- WILL MOVE
ALONG THE LINE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS
EXPANDING AS WITH THE ANTI
RECIDIVISM COALITION. I WE
APPRECIATE ALL THE WORK ON THIS
BUDGET THE VERY BEST MAN MADE
FOR THOSE WHO ARE LESS
FORTUNATE DISADVANTAGED. WE'RE
ESPECIALLY GRATEFUL TO SEE
INVESTMENTS FOR REHABILITATIVE
PROGRAMMING. AND RANCHERS THE
PARKED INCARCERATED PEOPLE
DURING AND AFTER INCARCERATION.
ADEQUATE FUNDING FOR THE OFFICE
OF YOUTH AND COMMUNITY
RESTORATION. ELIMINATION OF
EGREGIOUS CRIMINAL
ADMINISTRATIVE FEE IN A CIVIL
SOCIETY. THE COST FREE REMOTE
COMMUNICATION FOR INCARCERATED
PEOPLE AND THE PRIVATIZATION OF
REENTRY PROGRAMMING. AND
RECIDIVISM REDUCTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MINE COULD IMPOSE ON
SKEWS ME MADAM CHAIR GOING
FIFTY TWO PER GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND
STAFF AND MY NAME IS KATIE HERE
AND CALLING FOR CHILDREN. WE
WANTED TO THINK THE LEAD FOR
THE TWO AND FIFTEEN DOLLARS.
AND H. AFFECT. WHICH WILL HER
TO MORE IN THE OR THEM I HEALTH
WORKERS THEY NEED TO HE WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE IN FACT KOREA WOMEN.
THE 6% IN LANGUAGE ALLOWING FOR
THE CONTINUED OF. PAYMENTS FROM
THIRTY PER. THANK YOU. AND WE
WILL GO BACK TO LINE FOR ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAMCHAIR AND MEMBERS ON
HOLIDAY TO TURN BACK TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTY MY NAME IS JAMIE
MORGAN ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION. AND
OUR MISSION IS TO BE A
RELENTLESS FORCE FOR WORLD OF
LONGER YOUR LINE. SO IN OF
SUPPORT AT THE FINAL PRIOR THAT
WAS THE THAT NEW. SPECIFIC TO
HOW BACK IN RACIAL. FUN WITH
SUPPORT FOR BY THE- I JUST. FOR
UNDER MILLION ANNUALLY HOW WITH
IN RACIAL DRAFT. THE HELP WITH
THE NEXT. SYSTEM THE TYPICAL IF
YOU CAN MAKE OF CAN BE
ATTRITION AND PER. AND THE SPAM
THAT HOME BECAUSE- GRANT. AND
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR ALL OF
YOUR WORK ON UNIVERSE SCHOOL
MEALS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT. A
PROPOSAL IN FIND FIND- CAN YOU
JUST FOR MEDICAL TAILORED AND
INCREASED. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
MEDICARE THERE NO OTHER PART
ARE CUTE WITH THIS TO. GREAT WE
DIDN'T HAVE TO CUT A ALL THE
COMMENT. PUBLIC SO I'M GONNA
CALL ON- SEN DOLLY BECAUSE HE
HAD HAD HIS HAND UP WITH ANY
WANTED HE HAD A QUESTION- IN
THE LET'S SEE IF THERE'S A
OTHER MAY WHO HAVE COMMENTS
QUESTIONS BEFORE WE TAKE A
MOTION GO AHEAD SAID DOLLY.
THANK YOU NATURAL FOR BELIEVE
IT THE FOR. IN THE RECENT MADE
OF. THE FUTURE. ECONOMY WE I
THINK HE SAID IT THE GOOD FOR
LIKE FOUR YEARS I WANTED TO. IF
THEY INTO KIDS. SO SEEN ALREADY
THE- MORE OF THE HIGHEST. IN
AND IF THEY TOOK AN EIGHT COUNT
INFLATION THAT WAS MY QUESTION
MANAGER THANK YOU. I WILL LEAD
DEPARTMENT FINANCE ANSWER BUT I
DID WANT TO JUST POINT OUT MR
DAILY THAT WAS ELLIE- THAT WAS
REFERRING TO THOSE BUT- WE CAN
CERTAINLY HAVE DAILY- COMMENT.
ALSO GO AHEAD ERICA. THANK YOU
SENATOR DOLLINGER QUESTION AND
I'LL WOULD JUST EITERATE THAT-
OUR BUDGET INCLUDES LOWER
REVENUES- IN THE CURRENT IN THE
IN THE BUDGET YEAR AND IN THE
OUT YEARS THEN COMPARED TO THE
L. A. O. THE LA- REVENUES- DO
GROW. AT ABOUT AT LEAST FOUR
PERCENT- IN THE OUT YEARS AND
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE MAY
REVISION. AND THE- BUDGET
REVENUES INCLUDED EIGHTY ONE
TWENTY EIGHT. ROAD TO BE ABOUT
TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS AT
TWENTY BILLION IN IN IN A
DIFFERENCE IN TERMS OF THE GAP.
AND SO- I THINK EITHER
QUESTION- IS MORE IN LINE WITH
THE ALLEY ON REVENUE SO I'LL
TURN IT OVER. TO- MR PADDOCK.
MR PADDOCK AHEAD. OKAY YOU- YES
SORRY I THINK- OUR REVENUES I
WILL JUST KNOW- SENATOR DOLLY
PARTON. MY COMMENTS ON OUR
REVENUE OUTLOOK WE'RE
PARTICULARLY FOCUSED ON KIND OF
THE BUDGET YEAR PERIOD. AND YOU
pPARTICULAR. WE THINK IT. YOU
KNOW WE HAVE MORE CONFIDENCE IN
OUR IN OUR FORECAST OF COURSE
OVER THE NEXT. TWELVE TO
EIGHTEEN MONTHS. THEN MAYBE YOU
KNOW THERE IS GREATER
UNCERTAINTY THE FURTHER YOU GO
OUT. INTO THE FUTURE. AND SO.
THAT'S THAT'S THE FIRST POINT
THE OTHER POINT I MEAN I THINK
YOU'RE- COMMENTS ABOUT
INFLATION OR OR WILL TAKE AND-
YOU KNOW LIKE IN MY MIND ONE OF
THE BIGGER RISKS RELATED TO
INFLATION WOULD JUST BE. BETTER
IF THEY DID THE- BECOME HIGHER
THAN EXPECTED OR IF THE
CONSUMER EXPECTATIONS AN
EMPLOYER EXPECTATIONS BECAME
WHAT THEY CALL UNANCHORED- YOU
KNOW THAT THERE IS SOME
POTENTIAL THAT THE FED WOULD
HAVE TO ACT SOONER THAN THEY'RE
CURRENTLY SIGNALING TO THE TO
THE MARKET. AND IN THAT
SCENARIO THERE IS SOME
POTENTIAL THAT- FED TIGHTENING
COULD CAUSE THE ECONOMY TO SLOW
AND IN THAT SCENARIO WE WOULD
EXPECT- REVENUE GROWTH TO SLOW
AS WELL SO I MEAN I DON'T THINK
THAT'S OUTSIDE OF THE REALM OF
POSSIBILITY AT ALL BUT- BUT AT
THE SAME TIME I MEAN THERE. ARE
A LOT OF INDICATIONS THAT A LOT
OF THE INFLATIONARY PRESSURES
THAT WE'RE SEEING RIGHT NOW
I'LL HAVE TO DO WITH KIND.
BASED EFFECTIVE COMPARING-
CURRENT PRICE LEVELS TO WHERE
THEY YOU KNOW WHAT WAS GOING ON
ONE YEAR AGO WHEN THE ECONOMY
WAS IN A FREE FALL. AND SO
WE'RE KIND OF COMPARING THAT-
CURRENT PRICE CHANGES AGAINST-
ABNORMAL- BASE FROM LAST YEAR
AND SO YOU KNOW SOME OF THE
CHANGES TO THAT WERE SEEN OUT
OF A SUPPLY CHAIN- DISRUPTIONS
DUE TO THAT IS TO THE PANDEMIC
IN TRYING TO TURN THE ECONOMY.
YOU KNOW BACK ON IF YOU WILL
AND YOU KNOW SO THERE IS A GOOD
POSSIBILITY THAT A LOT OF THE
INFLATION THAT WE'RE SEEING
RIGHT NOW COULD PROVE TO BE
RELATIVELY TRANSITORY AND- NOT
WITH THAT- GOING FORWARD BUT IT
I MEAN I DON'T. I DON'T WANT
TO- YOU KNOW BE TOO SANGUINE
ABOUT THAT I THINK YOUR YOUR-
YOUR CONCERN ABOUT IT IS-
FOUNDED ON SOME REASONABLE-
BASIS SO. THANK YOU RON
CHURCHES. YEAH GO AHEAD JUST A-
SO JUST WANT TO SHARE THAT THE
THAT WE NEED TO BE TALKING OF
THE FACT THAT. HE WILL WORSEN
PLACE. AND WE EVEN FEW. NOT CAL.
BUT IT FEDERAL. I MEAN. SIX
TRILLION DOLLARS INTO THE
ECONOMY- AND THAT'S IN IT WITH
AND WE HAVE SEEN AND WE'VE
HEARD THAT WE'RE GONNA SEE
INTEREST RATES STAY FLAT-
THEY'RE EDGING UP A LITTLE BIT
BUT NOT AT THE RATE OF
INFLATION SO JUST A JUST A
COMMON IF IT. IF IT COST YOU.
BUT YOU KNOW TWICE AS MUCH TO
GET DONE WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO BECAUSE INFLATION AND THEY
KNOW IT REALLY IS GOING TO
IMPACT OUTCOMES OF OUR BUDGET
AND SO I JUST WANTED TO. SEE
WHAT THEY TOOK THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY. THANK YOU. I'M
SENATOR DRAWS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND I TOO WANT TO THANK
THE STAFF IN THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE AND MADAM CHAIR
EVERYONE ALL OF OUR OUR TEAMS-
I BELIEVE THAT- PUTTING MONEY
IN THE POCKETS OF WORKING
PEOPLE WORKING MEN AND WOMEN IS
WHAT LEADS TO A STRONG AND
RELIABLE ECONOMY AND I THINK SO
MUCH OF THAT HAS STARTED TO
HAPPEN ALREADY- YOU KNOW
THERE'S FEDERAL AND STATE
DOLLARS FOR BUSINESSES TO OPEN
AND- GET BACK ON THEIR FEET.
CONTINUE TO HELP THE
UNEMPLOYED- BUT MANY WERE LEFT
OUT AND THAT'S WHERE
GOVERNMENT- HAS TO STEP IN. TO
MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR PEOPLE WHO
WORK. TO MAKE A GOOD LIVING-
THEY SPEND THAT MONEY. YOU KNOW
THE WEALTHIER YOU ARE THE LESS
MONEY YOU SPEND- AND I REALLY
BELIEVE THAT ON THE GROUND WHEN
WORKING PEOPLE HAVE THAT MONEY.
THEY CIRCULATE THAT MONEY THEY
PAY THE RENT THEY BUY THE FOOD
THOSE ARE REAL DAILY THINGS
THAT WE COULD HELP AS
GOVERNMENT MAKE SURE. THEY
SPEND THE MONEY THEY DON'T PUT
THEIR MONEY IN OFFSHORE
ACCOUNTS- AND I WAS VERY PROUD
THAT THE KINDS OF THINGS THAT
ARE IN THIS BUDGET- ARE PART OF
THAT MAKING IT A WORKING
PEOPLES- ECONOMY WORK MORE
PEOPLE'S- BENEFIT THE- A FEW
PEOPLE. ABOUT TO HIGH ROAD
TRAINING PARTNERSHIPS- MONEY
TOO FOR WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
DONE MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE
REAL. TRAINING PROGRAMS- WITH
REGARDS TO OTHER ISSUES AND
LABOR YES THERE'S MONEY FOR THE
EDT. THREE HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ADDRESS THE WORK
WORKLOAD NEEDS AND OTHER ISSUES
AT THE E. D. D. TRANSPORTATION.
FIVE AND A HALF BILLION DOLLARS
IN NEW SPENDING FOR
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT'S OUR OPPORTUNITY TO PUT
PEOPLE TO WORK IN GOOD PAYING
JOBS. JUSTICE REFORM AND COURTS
LEMONADE IN CRIMINAL FEES AND
ADMINISTRATIVE FEES AND CIVIL
ASSESSMENT. THAT'S GOING TO BE
ABLE TO KEEP MONEY IN THE
POCKETS OF REGULAR WORKING
PEOPLE- RESTORING MONEY TO OUR
COURT- TO BE ABLE TO PROCESS
BACKLOGS AND PROVIDE LEGAL
SERVICES. OFFERS SO MANY
PEOPLE. LEGAL AID SERVICES FOR
RENTERS AND HOMEOWNERS. ARE
REHABILITATION REENTRY. I
VISITED REDUCTION TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS FOR THAT SO
THAT. MEN AND WOMEN WHO GET OUT
OF THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
WE MOVED- BARRIER SO THAT THEY-
RE ENTER SUCCESSFULLY AND THIS
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT ONE AS WE
GET PAST THIS PANDEMIC AND
REBUILD OUR ECONOMY IS RELIEF
FOR UTILITY THAT. A TOTAL OF
ALMOST FIVE BILLION DOLLARS FOR
YOU. OUR WATER DEBT RELIEF
ENERGY A UTILITY DEBT RELIEF
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE SO
I AM PROUD THAT WE'RE GOING IN
THE RIGHT DIRECTION STRONG
MEASURES ARE TAKEN UP WITH OUR
BUDGET AND I APPRECIATE. ALL OF
THE ORGANIZATIONS AND
INDIVIDUALS WHO COMMUNICATE
WITH OUR OFFICES TO. LET US
KNOW WHAT THEY THINK ARE THE
RIGHT SOLUTIONS ARE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU SENATOR
DRAWS OF SENATOR PANTS. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR- AND I KNOW
WE'VE- SPENT A LOT OF TIME
DEVELOPING THIS- VERY IMPORTANT
BUDGET AND LOOK FORWARD TO THE
ON GOING CONVERSATIONS IN
MINISTRATION TO- IN TERMS OF
FINALIZING THE BUDGET BUT I
JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY SAY THAT-
YOU KNOW PART OF THE REASON WE
ARE WHERE WE'RE AT. WE HAVE A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS- WITH-
COATED AND- AND WHAT RESULTED
FROM THAT AND SO ONE OF THINGS
I DEFINITELY WANT TO MAKE NOTE.
IS IN THIS LEGISLATIVE PROPOSAL
IS THE- FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE POINT ONE MILLION WITH-
FORTY THREE MILLION ANNUALLY
THEREAFTER TO BUILD AN
EQUITABLE PUBLIC HEALTH SYSTEM.
HOPEFULLY OF THE TREMENDOUS.
SUFFERING THAT'S HAPPENED AS A
RESULT OF- THIS PANDEMIC-
CERTAINLY HIGHLIGHTED-
DEFICIENCIES- AIMED AT YOUNG
PEOPLE BROUGHT UP EDT AND SOME
OTHER THINGS BUT THIS IS
ANOTHER AREA WHERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT DEFICIENCY- THAT-
HAS LED TO BOTH OF. PERSONAL
SUFFERING AS WELL AS ECONOMIC-
CHALLENGES- FOR OUR STATE SO I
DO WANNA THANK- OUR LEGISLATIVE
LEADERSHIP FOR- BE SURE THAT WE
ADDRESS THIS THE FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEM THAT WE'VE BEEN DEALING
WITH FOR OVER THE PAST MORE
THAN THE PAST YEAR AND SO
THANKS VERY MUCH I JUST WANTED.
TO EMPHASIZE THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN. SENDER
CALM WATER DID YOU HAVE YOUR
MARKET NO OKAY LET'S SEE IF
THERE'S A- ANY OTHER MIKE SAID
SENATOR MEN DID YOU HAVE YOURS
YEAH. ALL RIGHT. SO LET'S-
BEFORE ENTERTAIN A MOTION LET
ME JUST THANK OUR- SUBCOMMITTEE
CHAIRS IN OUR SUBCOMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR THE HEARINGS FOR
THE INTERACTIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND VETTING YOU
KNOW THERE WAS GREAT INPUT AS
SENATOR ALSO POINTED OUT. THAT
OR CALIFORNIANS IN OUR
ADVOCATES AND OTHERS GAVE US AS
WE STRUCTURED THIS- BUT OF
COURSE IT TAKES A LOT OF TIME
AND YOU ALL PUT IN THE WORK AND
I REALLY REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
AND I REALLY REALLY APPRECIATE
THAT EACH OF YOU AND- I MEAN
EACH OF YOU NOT ONLY THE CHAIRS
THE SEPT YEARS BUT THE MEMBERS
BROUGHT PARTICULAR EXPERTISE SO
WHEN WE TALKED ABOUT SOME OF
THE GREAT THINGS IN THIS BUDGET
FOR EXAMPLE AND- SENATOR
LAYERED SUBCOMMITTEE. JUST THE-
THE RESTRUCTURING OF OUR
FINANCIAL AID IN SUCH A WAY TO
REALLY HELP. SO THAT WE CAN
HAVE. PEOPLE GET THEIR HIGHER
EDUCATION WHAT IT WOULD
HOPEFULLY WITHOUT DEBT AND THAT
STRUCTURE IS- IS JUST AMAZING
AND OF COURSE- OVERSEEING A
PROP NINETY EIGHT THAT IS
HIGHER THAN WE'VE EVER INVITE
HIGHER INVESTMENT WE'VE EVER
HAD. AND IN OUR HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES SUBCOMMITTEE
SENATOR EGGMAN'S- YOU KNOW WE-
THERE WERE A LOT OF THINGS A
LOT OF OUR BASICS THAT HAD NOT-
LIKE THE MONEY FOR OUR FOLKS.
ARE DEVELOPMENTALLY ANOTHER
DISABLED FOLKS THAT HAD NOT
BEEN THERE DEPENDING ON THE
CHECKS THAT THE STATE PROVIDES
THEM THAT WE HAD NOT BROUGHT UP
THAT FUNDING TO THE RATE STUDY
THAT WE HAD. AND THOSE WERE
THOSE ADDITIONS AND OTHERS
INCLUDING INVESTMENTS IN OUR
LOCAL PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS
WERE NOT INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REVISE AND THAT SAID COMMITTEE
WAS REALLY INCREDIBLE AND
SEEING. SEEING THAT NEED
RECOGNIZING THAT NEEDED ADDING
IT AND OF COURSE IN SENATOR
DRAWS AREA. RECOGNIZING THAT-
YEAH DOES THAT- NOT EVERYONE.
IS EQUALLY BENEFITING FROM THE-
HE- WHAT WE EXPECTED VERY
STRONG ECONOMY AND RECOGNIZING
THAT MANY OF THE FINES AND FEES
THAT WE PUT ON PEOPLE ARE
REALLY- NEGATIVELY IMPACTING
THE MEN CAN PUT THEM IT'S NOT
JUST A SINGLE FEE BUT THEN AT
THE COMPOUND INTEREST IN
SECTION THE CAN RESULT IN YOUR
CARD BEING- TAKEN AWAY AND YOU
NAME IT AND IT'S A VERY BAD
SPIRAL AND SO. ARE HER
COMMITTEE RECOGNIZED THAT IN
BUILT IN SOME VERY IMPORTANT
ELEMENTS AS WELL AS THE WORK
FORCE TRAINING AND OF COURSE-
SENATOR COPYRIGHTS COMMITTEE
LOOKING AT DIFFERENT PARTS OF
OUR- STATE DEPARTMENTS THAT WE
HAD NOT PROPERLY INVESTED IN.
IT LIKE YOU DO DEEP AND MAKING
SOME VERY SMART INVESTMENTS
THERE AMONGST MANY MANY OTHER
THINGS- AND I DON'T THINK I
MISSED ANY OTHER CHAIRS BUT
ANYWAY IT WAS REALLY GREAT
WORK. AND I WILL CALL ON
SENATOR DOLLY- BUT GO AHEAD
SENATOR DOLLY TAKING A DRUG
TEST I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU-
FOR ALL YOUR HARD WORK AND I
KNOW WHEN WE WERE IN OUR BUDGET
HEARING WAS LATE AT NIGHT. I
THANK YOU AND THE OTHER
COMMITTEES- CHAIRMAN'S THE
SUBCOMMITTEES BUT ALSO WANTED
TO TAKE AN OPPORTUNITY THANK
OUR STAFF- I FAILED TO DO THAT
BEFORE AND THEY PUT A LOT OF
HOURS IN LATE NIGHT SUNDAY WE
HAD A- TWO HOUR MEETING. LAST
NIGHT- AND I WANT TO THANK OUR
STAFF I MEAN THEY'RE THEY'RE-
GOING ABOVE ME ON THIS IS A
HUGE BUDGET A LOT OF WORK WENT
INTO IT. AND I JUST THINK WE
SHOULD- GIVE THEM- THE
ACCOLADES THAT THEY DESERVE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DOLE AND- I%
KNOW THAT WE- AND I DON'T MEAN
TO SAY THIS THAT OR WE SHOULD
JUST THANK EACH TIME BUT- AND
WE WILL. EACH VOTE WE WILL
ACKNOWLEDGE THE INCREDIBLE WORK
THAT THE STAFF DID- FIRST I
WANT TO JUST POINT OUT THE
STAFF IN ALL THESE HEARINGS
WHETHER ITS SUBCOMMITTEES. FOR
THE BUDGET HEARINGS. THE STAFF
THAT HANDLE ALL OF THE TECH FOR
US AND THE- CALL ENDS AND- JUST
YOU NAME IT THAT'S A WHOLE.
NOTHER LEVEL OF LOGISTICS THAT
WE'VE NEVER HAD TO DEAL WITH
PRE PANDEMIC. SO THAT'S BEEN
AMAZING BUT OUR OWN BUDGET
STAFF HAVING BEEN. ANDI
COMMITTEE SINCE I STARTED IN
THE SENATE. I ALWAYS HAD GREAT
RESPECT FOR A BIRD TO STAFF.
BUT THIS YEAR I MEAN I HAVE
BEYOND RESPECT. THEY HAVE BEEN
IN FULL ON BUDGET MODE SINCE
THE DAY. THIS SESSION STARTED
NOW NORMALLY OF COURSE THEY GET
THERE THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET IN
EARLY JANUARY AND ANALYZE IT
BUT HEARINGS MAYBE DON'T START
TILL MARCH. AND THEN- YOU KNOW
WE PREPARE BUT WE TOOK ACTIONS
WITH THE- WITH THE SPEED. APRIL
RECOMMENDATIONS THE GOVERNOR
FOR THREE- GIVING STIMULUS FOR
EXTENDING OUR RENTAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAMS FOR ALL KINDS OF
THINGS BUT EACH OF THOSE EARLY
ACTIONS REQUIRED ENORMOUS
AMOUNT OF TIME ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE. AS WELL AS THIS KIND
OF VERY INTENSE THE MAY REVISE
BEING A VERY DIFFERENT PROPOSAL
THAN WHAT WE SAW IN JANUARY SO
I JUST HAVE. THE UTMOST RESPECT
FOR OUR BUDGET COMMITTEE STAFF
THEY'VE DONE PHENOMENAL WORK
AND THEY WILL CONTINUE TO
BECAUSE THIS IS OBVIOUSLY NOT
THE FINAL ACTION- BUT REALLY
REALLY APPRECIATE IT AND WITH
THAT I'LL TAKE A MOTION ON A.
B. ONE TWENTY EIGHT. GREAT SO
MOVED BY SENATOR MEN AND- MR
CONSULTANTS MR SEVEN CHARLIE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. AP ONE
TWENTY EIGHT THE MOTION TO PASS
SENATORS SKINNER. HI SKINNER HI
NIELSEN NO YES AND NO.
COPYRIGHT FEBRERO HI COURTESY.
TODAY THE HI DOLLY DALI NO THE
RAZA HI RAGO HI AIKMAN HI AMY
IN HIGH GROWTH FROM OTHER.
COMMA THERE HIGH LAYERS. CLEAR
HI ENQUIRE WHERE HI MELINDA MAN
RIGHT MAN HI NEWMAN HI NO HI
THE JOB. PENN HI PENN HI TURN.
WHAT CAUSED THE. WE WILL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN BECAUSE WE HAVE A
COUPLE OF MEMBERS AND COMEDIAN
MAYBE THEY'LL WANT TO COME BACK
DOWN TO ADD ON- BUT OTHERWISE-
I THINK. YOU OTHER FOLKS DON'T
NEED TO STAY WELL WE JUST TOLD
THE ROLE OPEN FOR OUR- FOLKS
RETURN SENATOR ALSO GO AHEAD.
MIKE FOR SENATOR DRUGS OR
POLICE. GO AHEAD I JUST WANTED
A I WANT TO CONGRATULATE OUR
CHAIR AND BEING A NEW
GRANDMOTHER. THANK YOU SENATOR
DRAWS SO BY APPRECIATED AND I
BE WHEN WE DO OUR FINAL BUDGET
ADOPTION I MAY MAKE SOME
COMMENTS ON IT BUT- IT'S
WONDERFUL BEAUTIFUL BABY RONAN
LITTLE GIRL- BUT- I THINK ALL
OF US WHO- MY DAUGHTER HAD A
DIFFICULT BIRTH AND- HE IS VERY
FORTUNATE TO HAVE. THE WHOLE
VILLAGE OF SUPPORT. BUT WE KNOW
THAT SO MANY NEW MOMS DO NOT
AND SO I AM SO PROUD OF THIS
BUDGET THAT IT IGNORE ALL AGES
AND RECOGNIZES THAT. THEIR
BIRTH IS HARD ON ANYBODY BUT
WHEN THEY'RE DIFFICULT THEY CAN
HAVE- A LOT OF REPERCUSSIONS
FOR YOU KNOW A GOOD NUMBER OF
WEEKS AND WITHOUT. PROVIDING
SUPPORT WHAT KIND OF. JUST WHAT
KIND OF DISADVANTAGE WE PUT
THAT NEW THAT NEW PARENTS AND
THOSE NEW BABIES AT AND SO THIS
BUDGET. HAS SOME GREAT THINGS
FOR NEW PARENTS AND BABIES AND
IT'S SO IMPORTANT BECAUSE WE
HAVE UNFORTUNATELY ARE WEALTHY
STATE IN OUR WEALTHY COUNTRY
HAVE A HIGHER. INFANT MORTALITY
RATE AND MATERNAL MORTALITY
RATE. THAN COUNTRIES AT
COMPARABLE OF COMPARABLE-
ECONOMIC STATUSES US AND THAT'S
JUST NOT APPROPRIATE SO I'M SO
PROUD. THAT WE HAVE ADDRESSED
THAT IN THIS BUDGET AND OF
COURSE AS BEING PART OF THAT
YOU KNOW I WAS PART OF THE
DISCUSSIONS TO INCORPORATED BUT
I NEVER THOUGHT. THAT I WOULD
ACTUALLY SEE WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT SO I JUST BUT THANK
YOU SENATOR DRAWS. ALL RIGHT SO
THOSE OF YOU WHO- I DON'T THINK
YOU NEED TO. WE DON'T NEED TO
HAVE THE FORM IN THE ROOM WHILE
WE WAIT WITH THE WORLD DO WE.
STANCES OF BOTH THOSE PEOPLE
WERE ON THOSE IF YOU DON'T NEED
TO WAIT WE'LL JUST HOLD THE
ROLE OPEN FOR- SENATOR STERN OF
US SENATOR Y. CASKEY IS HERE
GOOD- I BELIEVE IT'S ONLY
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE CONSIDER
STERN THAT HAVE TO ADD ON AND
SENATOR Y. CASKEY I WAS
THINKING OF THE SEPT YOURS BUT
YOU WEREN'T IN THE ROOM WHEN I
DID SO LET ME THANK YOU AND LET
ME THANK YOU FOR OF COURSE YOUR
DILIGENCE ON THE CLIMATE
RESILIENCY HEAT DROUGHT. AND
THE WATER PACKAGE. AT. YES.
YEAH.
I KNOW SENATOR STERN IS
CHAIRING BUT MAYBE WE COULD LET
US. THE STAFF IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOM KNOW THAT WE'VE GOT THE
ROLE OPEN SO IF YOU CAN COME.
OKAY GREAT AND THEN HE'LL BE
DOWN ALL RIGHT GREAT WONDERFUL.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN AS MR
SECOND SHOP YOU COULD- OPEN THE
RULE FOR THOSE TWO NUMBERS DOWN
ON. YEAH SORRY THE AREA I WILL
GO UP THERE BUT LET ME JUST I
HAVE TO CONCLUDE THIS GO AHEAD
ONE TWENTY EIGHT THE MOTION IS
TO PASS SENATORS GROWTH LINDA
IS. STERN STERN ALL RIGHT BY
CAL SKI. WORKOUTS SKI BY. HI
THIRTEEN NOSE. TO SEVEN BILL IS
OUT FIVE NOTES TO. THAT'S A B.
Y. TWENTY AND THANK YOU ALL AND
WITH THE ACT THE SENATE-
COMMITTEE ON BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW WILL ADJOURN. HI.